okay so it being uh 10 o'clock I'm going
to open the public hearing on House Bill
655. see we have a bunch of people there
if for those who haven't who want to
speak but have not put in a pink card
please fill one out and pass it up I'd
like to recognize representative Carol
McGuire
quickly Mr chairman that we're out of
pink cards at the moment so are we
thank you
yes yes someone should should somebody's
already working on it but
yeah
thank you Peter
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee
I'm Carol McGuire representing Merrimack
District 27 which is Allenstown
Dunbarton Epsom and Hooksett
this bill is a recommendation of the
study committee on oplc operations
and it is essentially a recodification
of the Licensing Laws to clarify who is
responsible for what and how and what
the relationships are
so the first part of the bill starting
on page two is an overview of the office
of professional licensure and
certification it's got the list of
boards which is all of Page Three and
most of all of page two and most of Page
Three it's got the unclassified officer
the duties and responsibilities
um
on on page five Roman 2 which starts on
line 10 is actually a bit of a a
duplication of
house bill
um
[Music]
where's that 445
so we we will need to consider how to
handle the duplication because it's not
identical but it's very close including
the five million dollar cap on the fund
uh what else we got there
the next fund is the
impaired professionals fund which is
which covers the cost of treatment for
doctors dentists Pharmacists and nurses
that I'm sure of and possibly others
that are impaired by drugs and or
alcohol and so they are that those
people pay pay for this and are assured
to it
all right
and what else then there is the
rulemaking authority
which includes a
um a notice that any existing law any
existing rule
is
still valid until it is revised
or repealed so that we don't have to
worry about uh
repealing all of our existing rules when
the the loss change
and then there are temporary licenses
license renewals procedures complaints
and investigations
more complaints sanctions licensing
procedures
Etc
and then there is the oversight
committee which was established by
Senate Bill 330 last year
which is in effect it has not been
staffed yet that is nobody's been
appointed to it that I know of
so we would that needs to be confirmed
that that's correct
I think it's fun
and then starting on page
13 there's a whole list of repeals
and both of sections and
line outs in other
in the in continuing sections of law
in order to coordinate with the first
part of the bill it starts with the
board of accountancy
and goes on down to um who's the last
one
reflexologists and Physicians
Etc
so
um
the intent is to clarify that the oplc
takes care of administrative
duties and the boards are responsible
for
the items that need professional skill
reviewing any license application that
is not perfectly obviously
suitable including criminal records that
are not perfect
discipline and sanction responsibility
of the of the boards
and what else and a continuing education
approving continuing education courses
those are the the responsibilities of
the board
and the oplc is in
a support function to all of them
and I believe this bill is going to
subcommittee on Friday
so if
I may not be able to answer your
questions but I'll try
thank you very much representative
any questions yes representative Lucas
so you mentioned that the disciplinary
stuff is belongs to the board but to
what extent is like organization and
administrative support and all that
being handled by oplc
it should mostly be handled by oplc so
they would have the staff that produces
the licenses that produces the agendas
for the board meetings that refers the
questions the complaints that look like
they they need to be resolved to the
board
okay follow-up follow-up so basically
the board would wouldn't have to would
just look at them make decisions based
on the professional
experience and then that would then go
back to oplc for whatever that's the
intent except that in the case of
discipline the board is essentially the
jury
and they determine whether discipline is
required and if so what if any penalty
should be applied they have the choice
of
uh sanctions yanking the license
additional training fines they have a
full gamut of penalties as appropriate
for the discipline okay thank you
anyone else
thank you very much representative thank
you
representative Wellington time
he calls me and interrupts us
because I'm told you're going to find in
this
okay I'm on mute
good morning folks my name is
representative will infantine uh from
Manchester
I'm an insurance agent by trade but I'm
also the vice chairman of the
electricians board
and I've been serving for about
like five years on that board
I wrote on my pink card I wasn't sure if
I liked this bill or not as parts of it
I do there's parts of it I don't
now I did not attend some of the summer
meetings but I'd have read
every single page of all the minutes
that were produced from this up
committee this summer
and
I don't have a problem per se with the
fact that the oplc was this big animal
that needed to be better organized
without question
um
the commissioner or um
tells us that well there were different
boards that don't meet they don't show
up we can't get a quorum they have their
own different letterhead and all kinds
of things were just going all over the
place so she's made Herculean efforts to
try to organize things
but I'm very cautious and very concerned
that some of the things have made gone a
little too far
and
part of the reason is because there are
so many of these different organizations
within the oplc
and not everyone has the same issues you
have a bunch of
from construction people to a massage
therapists to Funeral Directors they
don't all have the same things in common
they don't have all the same types of
issues
I would rather see this broken down into
three subsections within the oplc I'm
not trying to create anything different
but the construction related trades are
one thing the health and related trades
are another and then the professional
related trades are another
and I think the
trying to put all these things into one
it really doesn't match now
there's something in here about fines
the electrician's board has never had
fines when we have disciplinary issues
we bring someone in and we have
mechanisms allowing us to suspend their
license to make them go to additional
education we can ask them to have to
present every month where their jobs are
going to be so they can be inspected
more often and make sure they're doing
things now that may be much different
from a different organization
that maybe is used to or the only way to
get people to pay attention is to give
them a three thousand dollar fine
but I'm not sure it needs to be across
the board my biggest issue has to do
with page 20 of the bill
if if you see that has to do with
electricians
um
they've repealed a lot of their our
decision-making ability right now people
volunteer like myself to be in these
boards
and
as the chairman told me you know
sometimes we are the electrical
contractors police
people get in trouble they come to us we
adjudicate these things and there seems
to be a movement toward getting rid of
having boards be in that position
anymore
they want to have
um
experts brought in they don't they want
professionals to deal with
um
investigating a situation and giving a
fine or doing whatever going through
that whole hearings process when someone
has done something wrong well if that's
the case what are we here for
why do I bother with my time
10 months 10 10 meetings a year
and if you take away all the board's
Authority then why would why would
people like me volunteer why bother
you're going to have people even wanting
to go when the real meat and potatoes of
what we're supposed to do as our peers
through our through our trade
I can't really do anything
happened and I don't know what it is and
no one will tell me and I'm not a
conspiracy theorist but something
happened
where someone got in trouble or someone
didn't do what they were supposed to do
because there's been a major change in
the last year of what's going on in the
electrician's board we used to ask for a
lawyer to come in if we had a situation
now they're automatically there at every
meeting
now that the oplc wants to create a
matrix
of if someone gets in trouble what the
fines can be and what the procedure is
well if you tell everybody out in the
industry and everybody knows what the
the the the
um
penalty will be for violating the rules
don't make a business decision whether
or not oh well that's always going to
happen to me
okay
I guess that's a business decision I'll
take that three thousand dollar fine or
I'll take that uh fine that is in this
this Matrix and it's not always that
simple nothing is ever easy we had the
hardest meeting we ever had yesterday
with a convicted felon who created a
heinous crime and we had to make a
decision whether or not they should get
their license that's not going to be in
your Matrix
I don't want to go into every detail on
every single page here because I know
there's going to be a subcommittee in
two days
my opinion is there's been some major
changes for the good at the oplc
but you can't put everyone in the same
category and this bill kind of does that
and the same time on page 20 you take
away all these rulemaking disciplinary
action hearings appeals investigation
Authority that is in lines 13 through 21
that you want to appeal
some of it's just going a little too far
for me as a member of the electrician's
board so
great job by the subcommittee
um members of goalie and and everyone
else that was on that
um great start a lot of good things in
here to clean things up but
one of the things I've learned here in
my in my ninth term as a representative
is
to be cautious about going too far
because sometimes we do and then we have
to repeal it the following year and I
just want us to be very cautious with
this
thank you representative will you take
questions yes of course any questions
representative Schmidt
thank you very much Mr chairman and
thank you for being a long time
colleague for being here today because
uh uh I I think
I'll win it right down to one question
because I think to the degree you can be
here for the subcommittee on Friday
where we're going to take uh a lot of
these individual details uh you know
under the microscope your expertise
could be really helpful and I'm
wondering whether you're going to be
available
it was up in the year but now since you
asked I will be there thank you
any other questions
representative shewitt
thank you Mr chair
um
good morning to I one of my former
chairs
um
well in relation to representative
Schmidt's question do you think you will
be able to come to our subcommittee
meeting Friday morning yes I'll be there
thank you oops I'll wait for my
questions then
yeah you know I understand there's a
hearing there's a lot here
um I I was daunting when I looked at 77
pages and started going through it but a
lot of is obviously after the page 20
it's not a repeat but
um
it's amazing sometimes how one little
change and there'll be some people
testifying after me one little sentence
or two or three little words that I
didn't even think of reading it through
the first time that have some major
consequences
um and um so unfortunately it does have
to be studied almost line by line
thank you very much representative
um Elizabeth Eden oplc
good morning honorable committee members
thank you for hearing my testimony
um my name is Elizabeth Eaton and I am
an attorney at oplc and I'm here on
behalf of the board of psychologists
today so I'm taking off my oplc hat and
won't take questions regarding the
agency but I will be testifying on
behalf of the board today I have a
letter that the board
issued and I'll be reading that and I
have Dr walrath with me here he is also
on the board of psychologists
so the letter States
um
and it's regarding sections applicable
to the board of psychologists
the board of psychologists understands
that an efficient consolidation of
administration will be a positive
direction for the Department yet the
board is very concerned that the
statutory changes proposed in the new
oplc bill will greatly diminish the
effectiveness of the board the
protection of the public and fairness to
the occupations of the psychologists it
regulates the board sees many problems
with this bill and strongly urges the
committee to retain the bill in
committee to study the bill so that many
details that are harmful can be known
and resolved before sending it to any
further action in the house
below are just some of the major areas
of our grave concerns about the bill
we hope that the details of these and
our other issues could be discussed in
detail along with our other professions
as your committee could keep and study
the bill
while the board wishes to cooperate with
consolidating administrative supports it
is seriously concerned about the
eliminations in the bill that would
seriously affect the well-being of
patients and the due process of the
board
So Below I'm gonna
elaborate on some of the issues that the
board has the bill eliminates an
important protection to the individual's
private medical records in the repeal of
RSA 329b 22 6. this important privacy
protection safeguards the privacy of
medical records in the process of
Investigations when the person
complaining is not the patient and does
not have the right to share the records
another section the bill repeals an
important part of due process
eliminating the summary of findings from
an investigation that currently is
shared with the licensee before facing
settlement a step which gives a licensee
a review of the facts that have been
assembled against them the bill repeals
RSA 329b 22 9 which provides this Fair
due process
the bill also repeals RSA 329 B 22 8
that requires the immediate notification
of an allegation sending the copy to the
licensee
the board sees the value of informing
the psychologist because it protects the
public and brings immediate awareness to
the doctor of the issues that offended
the alleger especially important in
ongoing treatment
the bill also repeals RSA 329 B 2210
which will lose the distinction between
the status of an allegation versus a
complaint which is a very important
Safeguard of our boards statutes and
process
only after the board has determined that
an allegation could violate practice
laws it is elevated to be a complaint
and then it is formally investigated
under current law the allegation which
is the first communication to the
department is completely confidential in
all respects being protected in statute
from reporting by the licensee
practicing their occupation of
psychology
once it becomes a complaint if
reportable in the doctor's
professional accountability it is
reportable in the doctor's professional
accountability to insurers hospitals and
practice associations
finally the board of psychologist hopes
to be helpful in the process of making
the department streamlined but also
effective in protecting the public and
In fairness to the individuals
practicing their occupations
the board requests that you retain the
billing committee so that we and others
can facilitate the reconciliation of
these issues for Better Health boards
safer practice and fairness to the
occupations
thank you very much all you take
questions
okay while wrath can also help me answer
great any questions
representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman well as has
already been alluded to this bill is
going to subcommittee uh where we can
get into the these details and try to
work them out uh so are you are you or
any member of your group going to be
able to be here to assist us in that
task on Friday
um personally I have to look at my
calendar as I'm representing other
boards in front of committees I would
if I can be there I will
I'll certainly make every effort to be
there right now I have some conflicts
but I think I can work those out
follow-up so uh you you I'm speaking now
to the attorney I didn't quite get your
name I apologize but
um you've already gotten into some of
the details of issues that you have a
problem with so the question is uh how
we can
other than just striking that particular
section of the bill getting at it is is
going to require some kind of a list to
work on could you provide that if you're
not able to be there on Friday uh I I
would certainly work on that yes thank
you
yes representative Lucas thank you maybe
this already covered by uh what what uh
represent Schmidt asked but you read off
a number of sections you had issues with
uh if you could provide written
testimony with that if we don't already
have it
certainly um yeah we can
give you the list that we just had thank
you
anyone else
I do have one question
um you're the second people now to
testify that repeals are a concern
within within this bill
um during its creation during the
process of it were the boards
um invited into the conversation
as to how this was going to be developed
sure
yeah I'm not aware of that that hasn't
come up in any of our recent board
meetings okay very good
well thank you very much thank
you um the chair will call Douglas
osterhout and Mike Porter
representing oplc
morning
not yet good morning I'm Mike Porter I'm
the investigations bureau chief uh oplc
division of enforcement
good morning Mr Vice chair and members
of the committee my name is Douglas
osterhau and I am currently general
counsel for oplc executive director
Courtney uh gives your apologies for not
being able to be here today she's
currently back on her way back from
Washington D.C but she will be at the
subcommittee meeting on Friday as will I
um so I do have the ability to answer
questions today but just so everyone's
aware I'll be at both
um I think representative McGuire did an
excellent job of sort of presenting the
bill oplc does not take a position on
the bill we were actively involved in
the SB 330 study committee that occurred
last year we were asked at the end of
that study committee to propose language
at the that would meet the
recommendations of that subcommittee so
I do have some of those listed today
um but I think we've heard a lot of
those already it was the main point of
that was to carve out sort of
responsibilities between the boards and
between the oplc and a lot of that came
down to who would process licenses I
think there's a lot of concerns and I
can I can either address things today or
we can wait till Friday I think that's
sort of
a little guidance as to how you would
like me approach
I think for the most part we'll leave
the larger detail for the Friday
subcommittee yeah I think that's where a
lot of that will happen Okay so so then
just the the broad overview then
um we carved out the sort of discipline
in process but the administrative side
so
um Council for individuals hearings
officers when investigations could be
triggered previously every if we were to
receive a complaint an investigation
would need to go before the board we
would need authority to investigate and
this is just one example
oftentimes depending on when a complaint
would come in there could be
significant delay in actually
investigating this just does things like
give the oplc the authority to begin
investigations immediately as soon as a
complaint comes up the the overall
arching theme of this entire bill is
oplc controls the process right
licensing applications come in we're
able to process applications if there's
any difficulty if there's any denials if
there's any discretion those things go
before the board complaints come in we
review those complaints in the first
instance we're able to investigate them
we make recommendations to the boards
the boards still retain the authority to
make the decision on whether to proceed
with discipline they still have the
authority to hear the case and decide if
discipline is appropriate they still
have the abort authority to make the
sanctions that that's all in their
control still other things that are
still in their control the license might
come into us we might do the criminal
background check the board words still
have the authority to set criteria
for what what needs to be contained in
the application the type of education
that's necessary the kind of in on the
field training those sorts of things all
that criteria still
set by the board word processing the
license as administrative function
so these are the types of changes there
was mention of a non-lapsing fund at
it's currently at the end of the
biennium oplc any funds uh will lapse
into the general fund it was the
recommendation of the subcommittee that
the funds oplc being a self-funded
agency our money comes from the
licensees and the belief was that money
should be spent on the licensees so the
non-lapsing fund was created or was
proposed in an effort to keep that money
where it should be hopefully lower costs
because we aren't resetting back to zero
every two years and then also allow us
to retain some money for
basic functions maintaining laptops new
desks the sort of regular the
requirements of an agency
um
I think a lot of the
other information that I could present
to you today would be probably more
appropriate for Friday I do have
responses to the board of psychology's
letter written testimony today I also
provided before the hearing started
written testimony everyone should have
received a copy of that from the
executive director sort of explaining
our position
um
so we are we are here to answer
questions if you have any and uh again
we will be present Friday
um great before we do thought would you
mind just giving some brief responses to
the board of psychology it would give us
a sense I think of potential other
conflicts that will come if we won't
have to go into every group in detail
but
absolutely some rationale for why
certain things were repealed would be
helpful
so I I know you don't have
a copy of the boards written testimony
in front of you but essentially
um
I was attorney Eaton went through and
read the four bullet points I had
responses to the four bullet points so
bullet point one reference privacy and
medical records RSA 329 b296
um and in the proposed language page
seven line 34 uh the proposed RSA 310 9
section 4 says allegations of misconduct
received by the office information and
Records acquired by the office during an
investigation reports and Records made
by the office because of its
investigation shall be held confidential
and shall be exempt from disclosure
requirements under RSA 91a and then it
goes on unless such information
subsequently becomes part of a hearing
or publicly disclosed we believe that
captures the entire
foreign
investigative record is a confidential
record anything in that record is a
confidential record uh not subject to
91a or any other disclosure okay outside
of the hearing process
uh bullet point two reference summary of
findings from an investigation currently
shared with the licensee before facing
settlement RSA 29b229 if you look to RSA
31010 proposed language 8 which is on
page 9 Lane 24. at any time or during
disciplinary or non-disciplinary
remedial proceedings complaints may be
dismissed or dispose of in whole or in
part A by written settlement agreement
approved by the board provided that any
complaint complainant shall have the
opportunity before a settlement
agreement has approved by the board to
comment on the terms of the proposed
settlement it is a nature of settlement
agreements to review stipulated facts
I'm unaware I used to litigate I'm
unaware of a situation where an
individual would settle a case they're
involved in without at least having
understanding of the facts and
stipulating to the facts that is a
nature of settlement agreements
um bullet 3 which references 329 b228
requires immediate notification of an
allocation
RSA proposed 329
um excuse me 31062 which is page five
line 35 rule making Authority the
executive director of The Office of
professional licensure and certification
shall adopt rules relative to RSA 541a
for the following two such
organizational and procedural rules
necessary to administer the boards in
the office including rules governing the
administration of complaints and
investigations hearings disciplinary and
non-disciplinary proceedings inspections
Payment Processing procedures and
application procedures
um already in place as of August of last
year is PLC rule 20404 initiation and
conduct of Investigations when an
investigation occurs an investigators
shall contact such persons conduct such
inspections and examine such records and
other documents as a reasonable
necessary to make a recommendation as to
whether further action should be taken
based on the allegation
in question the practice of the lplc is
when a complaint is received one of the
first things we do in a typical case is
to reach out to the subject of the
complaint and ask for a response there
may be situations here and there where
at the request of a law enforcement
agency we hold back but that is standard
practice that's that's how it works and
it's in rule and then the final bullet
um
Bill repeals 329 b22x
um which will lose the distinction
between a status of an allegation versus
a complaint RSA 31094 which is in the
bill page 7 line 34.
allegations of misconduct received by
the office information and Records
acquired by the office during an
investigation
and reports and Records made by the
office because of its investigation
shall be held confidential it's the same
it is the same logic or languages before
that I already cited so I'm not going to
read it to you again I'll save you that
um
but from the office's perspective the
complaint is is just the vessel through
which the allegation right a complaint
is the form the allegation is on that
form we aren't making the distinction at
the lplc between the complaint and the
allegation we don't see there being a
functional distinction between a
complaint and an allegation other than
one might be a piece of paperwork one is
the words on that piece of paper
so we don't hopefully these answers
alleviate some of the concerns we're
very concerned about the confidentiality
of our records we're very concerned
about the privacy of the citizens of New
Hampshire and these things we believe
have been approached in the proposed
language
uh so that's what I had for the board of
psychology you are representative Simon
Vice chair also had a question about
were the boards given an opportunity to
get uh the public hearing SB 330 it was
public many members of boards did come
and testify before that uh study
committing last year and had an
opportunity to provide input into
um
into sort of the final product
so and the recommendations that came out
of the board
great yes representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman
perhaps I can I'm very appreciative of
the testimony you've offered up to this
point and I know you're going to be
available on Friday but perhaps when we
where we have the whole committee here
and also a number of practitioners in
their uh their uh board members and so
forth perhaps I can drill down into one
thing that that I think will be
understandable uh to the to the group
even if this is a first uh investigation
of this sort that they've done and I was
part of a subcommittee about I don't
know 10 or 12 years ago that involved
former representative Neil Kirk
and former Attorney General Sarah
Blodgett representation we have a ton of
pink cards so if we could get to the
question quickly okay here comes the
question so uh the the the the the issue
it at hand at that particular time was
the privacy of individual patients
Records
who have seen psychologists or other
mental health practitioners and it was
recognized in this and the statute was
amended to bring in the idea that these
records uh needed to be absolutely
secure and they could not be made
available uh in a large scale for some
kind of
I don't want to call it data mining but
if you if you if you were after a
psychologist perhaps for a
billing violation
you didn't really have to see that that
the records of the patient uh their
actual
consultation with the psychologist and
the idea that that potentially is going
to be repealed here is very troubling to
me because the people go to mental
health practitioners obviously for uh
for consultation with regard to their
deepest issues and problems that cannot
be available to the to anyone other than
that psychologist and the patient in my
view so this proposed repeal how it will
that be handled
uh thank you for your question so right
now every every piece of paper that we
receive during an investigation an
ongoing active investigation is held
confidential
if the matter reaches a level of
adjudication where the board has
determined that this matter needs to be
heard before the board
aspects certain aspects of those records
would become public but I also want to
say that for and I'll use juveniles for
example juveniles or sexual assault
victims and so forth those can be heard
and non-public there are certain
documents that would remain sealed as
part of the record the respondent the
licensee who's been charged would have
access to review it to prepare their
defense for due process purposes but at
the end of the day every document we
receive is held under confidentiality
part of an investigation that that and
we run into this with with attorneys uh
all the time defense counsel or when
we're trying to subpoena records
um oftentimes they require a subpoena
under HIPAA and then they will determine
the records that need to be sent and and
sometimes we have you know spirited
conversations on those
um but records that we receive from
Health Care Providers are held to the
strictest of confidentiality and even
during the hearing process at times
boards will go into non-public even
during a public hearing to discuss
sensitive information that is ongoing
now we had a medical case we had a
um a couple of medical cases couple
Board of Nursing cases one involved the
juvenile who was severely abused and
they were able to go into non-public to
discuss those very sensitive records
um while still giving them the
respondent due process because that's
the key here so I hope that answered
your question
we'll look at it more on Friday thank
you
any other questions yes representative
Gerhard
thank you chairman
as far as
there's no fiscal note I'm just curious
as to how much do you expect says it
hasn't been calculated
so
as far as the workload that you expect
to increase do you have any idea if I'm
just looking at how much of the fee is
going to go up now for the licensees
thank you for the question actually I
think the opposite is true I think what
we're doing is
um
putting ourselves in an opportunity to
lower the fees for the licensees both by
streamlining processes across the board
out lowering costs and then also with
the non-lapsing fund the ability to use
those funds for things down the road the
goal is to lower fees for licensees
thank you
yes representative O'Brien
Mr chairman just a quick question
um can you answer under 91a there is
that like you say cause for
confidentiality reasons when the person
may be harmed or such in the case of
HIPAA and everything else like that
could you quote that number so that the
committee can research it themselves and
see exactly what it says RSA 91a5 A5 yes
sir thank you
foreign
other questions
yes representative true
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um somebody had testified earlier I
think it was electrician but I'm not
sure
uh that
he was concerned about the board the
electrician's board being stripped of
its Authority
and
and why would people want to be on the
board anymore
I thought I heard you say that the
boards would not be losing
could you address that absolutely thank
you for the question I think that's a
good point of clarification uh so so
some of the authority that would come
away from the from the board would be
um sort of kick-starting the
investigation would be appointing the
hearing officer would be appointing
counsel to adjudicate the matter they
again that's all process related these
are things we are currently doing
currently we have to wait for board
approval to start an investigation which
can cause significant delays the boards
however would still retain the authority
to set the criteria necessary for
licensure including
education the kind of schooling maybe
apprenticeships out in the field sort of
work experience those types of things
they would retain the ability to decide
whether a matter goes to adjudication or
not they would sit there and be the
final decision makers as to whether
discipline occurs or sanctions are
applied so so really we're trying to
again
give oplc control over the process and
the board's control over the substance
the criteria
thank you
yes representative Grote
thank you Mr chair so I understand that
oplc is trying to go to an online
process for licensing
that's a question I understand is that
correct
yes that is correct uh we we currently
do have ability
to receive applications online one of
the major things we are trying to do to
streamline the process to keep costs
down to improve customer service for all
licensees in New Hampshire all
applicants is a better system and we
actually are implementing very soon a
newer better system for licensees so
that is correct yes
follow up
so is it necessary for this type of
legislation to be carry forth if we want
to use that online process in the manner
in which you intend to
I believe so I think the majority of the
language in the bill is sort of
pre-existing language in 310 A1A right
now and as uh director Courtney likes to
joke we're running out of letters so one
of our shifts is to 310 but a lot of the
language it's very very similar and then
as multiple people have pointed out uh
roughly the back 50 pages of this bill
is sort of that clean up language in
order just to clarify who has fee
setting Authority who can appoint
investigators who can appoint hearing
officers those types of things again
clean up for process versus criteria
follow up
so in determining the administration of
these things it's your it's the opl
stuff itself that does that correct
I'm sorry let me rephrase that question
you're the one under under the division
of enforcement for example how those
um
how the
complaints are enforced and how
basically everything that's underneath
oplc
is administered whether it's through
enforcement or whether it's through
legislative legislation appearances it's
all done through oplc it is it is your
staff that does that correct
that's a great question representative
So currently for the I can speak for the
enforcement
um not every board has the same
complaint process so we have
approximately 54 different boards and
I'll give you an example Real Estate
Commission every complaint that comes in
shall be investigated regardless of
whether it warrants it or not whereas
Board of Nursing reviews all complaints
first and then those that meet the
threshold are then sent to us Board of
Medicine receives a complaint the Board
of Medicine is very unique in that we
receive written complaints we receive
lawsuits from Superior Court we receive
insurance claims and then we also have
hospitals or other medical facilities
that report potential wrongdoing so
there's four Avenues there
what this does is it streamlines the
process for just jump starting the
complaint for the public right so for
the public if they if they feel they've
been aggrieved they don't have to worry
about saying well geez does this board
do this or that it's going to be one
process across the board for how we
receive the complaint okay which which
in turn houses the allegations inside
um that would streamline that for us and
as attorney osterhout had mentioned
there have been unfortunate times where
there's been significant delays as a
result of the complaint process and I
won't give you the specific case
some delays come in when we have to
potentially pull a board together
emergently not for a suspension but in
order to begin an act what's called an
ex parte investigation we've received
information of alleged wrongdoing that
that may place an individual in Jeopardy
we Loop in law enforcement and we
ourselves want to get that investigation
underway it can take because people have
schedules it can take days to get that
when those days those precious hours
could be the difference so from an
enforcement perspective this this really
streamlines the complaint process and
how we accept those complaints the
boards are the ultimate Arbiter of every
complaint they will decide whether they
dismiss it whether it goes to adjudice
they wish to issue discipline post post
adjudication that remember
remains all with the boards and then I
want to be very clear thank you
thank you
representative Aber
thank you Mr chair
a little Act of listening on my part so
as I've been listening to the testimony
I'm trying to figure out and I think I
finally understand where we're going
with this so what you're saying is you
have several you have olpc on top and
then you've got several boards sitting
all underneath
a complaint of anything that could come
in that could have legal ramifications
comes in where an investigation is
necessary to launch it and what you're
trying to do is streamline it at an olpc
level to make sure that it's all treated
consistently so if I compare it to a
harassment complaint that we would get
in my own company we have one in a very
small
um small example we have one set of
harassment officers they treat those
cases of whatever may come in the same
exact way every single time and follow
the same policy and so what you're
saying is
having several boards and several
different people creates more
inconsistencies in opening the state up
for lawsuits that were treated One Way
versus another way and very
inconsistently is that basically what
this is thank you I couldn't have said
it better yes
any other questions
thank you very much gentlemen
Lynn Stanley
and a SW New Hampshire Social Workers
there you go there we go thank you
for the record my name is Lynn Stanley
I'm the executive director of the
National Association of Social Workers
New Hampshire chapter my testimony will
be incredibly brief we on the whole are
very much in support of this bill we
applaud oplc's efforts to streamline uh
what it must be a Herculean task uh our
only concern that or our primary concern
is specifically naming who is on the
investigation
and so it can be assigned we would like
to have uh the content expert be
somebody who is who shares the same
license as the person who's being
investigated uh in the case of social
workers this would be other licsws who
are also governed by the board of mental
health practice we will have a
representative at the Friday meeting and
I'm happy to take any questions if there
are any
any questions
yes representative shewitt thank you Mr
chair
um I assume you have looked at the the
bill that
deals with your particular profession uh
did you see anything in that that would
indicate that you would not have input
as to an investigator
uh there is in the language and I don't
have it in front of me that it may be
content experts
and we would just want the language to
indicate that there that there is a
Content expert that there is somebody
who is who shares the same license as
the person who's being investigated
but we'd uh if I can continue with that
we absolutely see a benefit to having
somebody who is experienced with Pros
due process law administration also
being a part of the that process
any other questions
yes representative can you be available
for this subcommittee on Friday we will
have a representative there uh on Friday
for the subcommittee thank you
absolutely
no notes
thank you very much
Celia Oliver PhD
New Hampshire Psychological Association
good morning I'm Dr Celia Oliver
and I'm very happy to be here today and
to speak with you I am representing the
New Hampshire Psychological Association
and that is a state chapter of the
American Psychological Association
and just a non-profit member
professional supported
um organization
so
um I'm here at state to provide both
verbal and written testimony on behalf
of nhpa
and we are essentially supporting this
legislation and along with our
colleagues at the board of psychologists
licensing board and
um to a somewhat lesser extent the
social workers although we have a lot in
common with them we have a number of
concerns and so
um we just want to make sure that while
we're supporting this the intent of
everything being streamlined and more
consistent that we don't lose some of
the things that are working for us I
know that others have already addressed
the confidentiality I just want to bring
it up again it's an incredibly important
aspect of the work that we do and it's
important for the citizens and our
patients to have this confidentiality
and especially in circumstances where an
allegation might be filed by essentially
a third party like family member it
could even be an ex-spouse
or where disclosure feels necessary to
another agency like law enforcement so
in those areas you really open
yourselves up for information sensitive
information getting out from the medical
record
so
um we are concerned about that we're
also really concerned about this
differentiation of allegation versus
complaint because for us
along with an excuse me
along with a number of other
Mental Health Providers we are frequent
we're constantly being recrudentialed
and we're asked in these recondentialing
um applications is there any pending
complaint
well if something is navigation then
we're under no obligation to report it
and that all that allegation could be
something very trivial so of course
we're not going to report that but if it
has moved into a complaint then we are
required to report that and most likely
our credentialing will either be denied
or severely restricted so that
distinction is very important to us also
as the board of psychologists has
pointed out knowing that an allegation
has been made because we are treating
very sensitive potentially volatile
cases and we need to know that something
is not going right with this this
patient that we might not have been
aware of before although you know
hopefully we were but sometimes that
happens so we need to know what's going
on we need that done as quickly and
timely as possible
and then in terms of an investigation of
potential misconduct again like our
colleagues the social workers and along
with the board of psychologists were
very concerned about who's being
assigned to those investigations
our profession like many others is very
complex and has many subcategories I've
been a licensed psychologist in New
Hampshire for 25 years and so I was
licensed originally with Board of mental
health practice and then under the board
of psychologists I've been very active
in the profession for all those years
and
in terms of Investigations because we
have such complex areas of specialty
I would not for instance be at all
qualified to investigate one of my
colleagues who's a neuropsychologist I'm
a clinical psychologist I would not be
able to understand the nuances that
they're professional enough to make an
ethical investigation so I'm very
concerned not only that the investigator
is licensed as a psychologist but also
that there is some sort of pool of
investigators that can be pulled from
that matches up and you're a
psychologist with a neuropsychological
investigation
and that this pull-up investigators
because if you only have one expert then
you can imagine how there's opening for
personal bias that maybe that
investigator isn't even aware of but if
you're working together then your
colleagues can hold to each other's
accountable and I always believe more
brains are better than one so
these are some of our concerns we will
have a representative at the
um working committee on Friday and that
is John dojoy and so I am open to any
questions or anything I can provide and
I appreciate you hearing my testimony
thank you thank you for your testimony
any questions yes representative a bear
thank you Mr chair
so what you're asking for is more of an
accountability from olpc during the
investigation back to you
back to the individual licensees yes
follow up
I think what you mean is accountability
back to the board not back to the
licensee is that correct
it depends on the situation that we're
talking about because a specific
allegation would be about a specific
licensee
so we would want the license C to be
informed and fully kept prized there
would also be circumstances where we
would want Ford who is making the
disciplinary
determinations
and I think
possibly other decisions prior to that
where the board of psychologists would
be the ones to be notified
it depends on the circumstance
follow-up follow-up
shouldn't wouldn't it be wise for that
to go from in just a hierarchy of
in the hierarchy pyramid to go from olpc
to the board an appointed board member
and I would like to hear from the
electrical Association again on that
thank you
I am not certain what I'm concerned
about in that potential scenario that
I'm imagining as a practitioner is that
there would be such a delay if it was
going from the oplc to the board and
then to me as the practitioner
where it might be something I need to
know directly and as close to immediate
as possible
so those are our concerns and again this
is about how these things get
implemented
thank you
any other questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you
Michael Phillips
lamura psychology subtle sorry
Psychological Associates
thank you Mr chairman and committee
members
um I want to speak uh about this bill in
a couple of ways one is is that there
are parts of it that I support I believe
that there are many ways that we could
increase I'm sorry Mr chair can you
please can you also please restate your
name because sure my name is Dr Michael
Phillips I'm a clinical psychologist and
I'm the owner of lamora Psychological
Associates practice in Nashua and in
Bedford
um I was present during the hearings
about 10 to 12 years ago where we
revised the protocols for the board of
mental health practice to address some
of these issues and despite what the
council for the oplc had said about
these things never happening where uh uh
licensees would not be aware of the
strength of the case against them that
was routine practice before we reformed
the rules going through gel car three
times against the board of mental health
practice back then in addition licensees
were not informed that they had
complaints against them at that time and
we had situations where there were
people who were unstable and they would
generate a complaint and that could
create risk both for them and for the
psychologists to continue to treat them
while we were waiting to be informed
that there was in fact a complaint filed
these are the things that we were
concerned about back then and that's why
we argued for those rules and they got
those rules in place and we're now
looking at having all of that revoked
again and recreating those dangerous
situations in practice and that's really
important to us
I have a number of objections to this uh
Bill I'm going to limit my speech today
and I'm going to submit written
testimony to be considered on Friday but
I want to just kind of talk about it
more globally because I think that we
have a balancing act here on one hand we
have administrative Simplicity or
efficiency and on the other hand we have
accuracy and Justice and we can't lean
in either direction on this we have to
balance both I mean if you want to get
administrative Simplicity we could flip
a coin every time a complaint comes in
it would be really fast we'd have a
decision immediately we would have very
little Justice and accuracy right
nobody's proposing that we do that but I
believe that this bill leans heavily in
the direction of administrative
Simplicity
and it costs us in terms of justice and
and accuracy
um I think that right now we're trying
to simplify a process for 53 very
different boards or 54 very different
boards into one routine process it's one
size fits all and as a really big guy
I've had familiarity with one size fits
all and typically it's one size fits no
one and I think that's what I'm trying
to avoid and this kind of a circumstance
um you know the the intent as stated is
laudable that the boards are going to
retain authority over profession related
information and I and that uh you know
that the just the nuts and bolts of you
know administering licensing and things
like that is going to be with the oplc
but that's not what the bill says the
bill doesn't say that at all
um basically uh you know what they do is
they tend to take away all of our
rulemaking Authority they take away our
ability to run the hearings and write
rules that would regulate the hearings
um and so I think that these are
significant pieces uh that we would need
to be able to have an effective and fair
set of solutions when we're adjudicating
hearings they Define us as triers of
fact but the investigation is conducted
by the oplc not necessarily with
professionals that are informed about
the
um the ethics of our profession which
are very complex or even the
professional specifics uh the presiding
officers are appointed by the oplc the
procedures in the hearing are written by
the oplc again in a one-size-fits-all uh
kind of a fashion and um and that's not
going to work it didn't work in the past
which is what led to the effort to
reform all of these rules 10 to 12 years
ago and now we're aiming back in that
direction again and I think it could it
it's going to be a big problem
um
I think uh at least with psychologists
in addition there are some unwarranted
increases in penalties that are going to
create a potential burden on licensees
the potential fines have been increased
by 50 percent from 2 000 uh to three
thousand dollars for an individual uh
fine and 200 per day to three hundred
dollars per day but that's really the
smallest piece of it uh section 310
colon 12 Roman 5 grants the ability to
charge the licensee for the cost of the
investigation and the prosecution of the
complaint against them this I believe is
an egregious uh violation of due process
it builds Upon A previously passed
statute that
RSA
332-g colon 11 which somehow passed in
2016 without commentary from a single
board
um and uh at least that statute had a
ten thousand dollar limitation
as it's proposed within this current
bill there is no limitation so if
there's a hundred thousand dollar
investigation or a five hundred thousand
dollar investigation
um the uh
you know they have the ability to
enforce that the collection of that onto
a licensee
that to me seems
um completely unfair
um in addition uh the standard of proof
and licensure complaints is very low
from somewhere depending upon the issue
preponderance of the evidence to uh
clear and convincing evidence that's
between 51 to 75 percent certainty
um uh the standard of proof in criminal
cases is beyond a reasonable doubt which
is typically thought of as about 95
certainty right but in criminal cases
they don't charge for the cost of the
investigation to the criminal who's
being charged you know and so we're
looking at this huge potential penalty
to be enforced upon licensees
um and I gotta ask why and I think one
of the things is that it goes back to
what we talked about initially
um the way the boards used to do
business is they would sit you down and
say you know this is what we're offering
you we're not going to tell you the
strength of our case against you but it
could be a lot worse if you don't agree
to a settlement and they would use that
leverage to achieve settlements and this
is pre-2010 right so it's a long time
ago since then things have gotten a lot
better back at that time we were
identified as the most dangerous state
in the country to practice and we
couldn't get psychologists to come to
this state okay since then that's not
the case psychologists are coming here
regularly our population of licensed
psychologists has grown I think that's a
good thing I don't think the solution is
just open the doors to make license or
easy I think we want to bring in
competent qualified people we want to
hold them to good standard practice we
want to be able to enforce penalties as
we need to if they violate those
standards but we don't want to make it
so onerous that nobody wants to come and
work here that would be a bad outcome
and I think that's where that's headed
um I think we can do much better than
this we need to do much better than this
I think this bill needs a lot of work
it's like a cake that's been in the oven
for about 20 minutes it has some shape
but it can't hold its own and it's not
ready for consumption
thank you for your testimony any
questions
yes representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman good morning Dr
Phillips uh so you referenced a moment
ago an increase from two thousand to
three thousand is that up to 3 000 or is
it 3 000 on the news I think it's up to
up to yeah okay so there's some
reflection for increased costs and so
forth so it it could it still could be
two it could still could be 1999 as
opposed to
2001 right it could be um I think in in
many kinds of cases you'll you can have
protection against claims like that
where your insurance will cover the cost
of fines I consulted with the APA trust
who I have my malpractice insurance they
don't cover the cost of fines and so
that would come out of my pocket not the
just the 3000 if I had to pay for the
investigation my malpractice insurance
would not cover that that would be a
direct bill to me
thank you
anyone else
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
I have to apologize I can't quite make
out the last name but Robert Wallace
maybe board of psychology
of those of you okay so we're we're good
Elizabeth pep
um if you could turn your microphone on
please for us oh did I turn it up okay
I'm Elizabeth Rupp I live in Manchester
New Hampshire I am a licensed
acupuncturist I neither serve on the
board nor am I part of the State
Association I've been before this
committee before to say that neither one
of those organizations represent me or
my co-workers that's why I'm here I work
at a low-cost high volume practice
whereas the rest of the acupuncturists
work more in a high cost low volume
practice
so I'll come to the some sub
subcommittee meeting I just saw that
acupuncture was in this bill I can't
even find it right now because this is
so long and I saw things were being
repealed but I couldn't tell what so I'm
just here to find out more
do you have any questions
any questions
seeing then thank you very much
um Kelly lootkey
latke
Mr chairman maybe we could have people
with somewhat unusual names spell their
names because I don't like
approximations in that regard would you
mind spelling your name please that
husband of mine gave me this name
l-u-e d as in David t as in Tom
K as in Kelly e is an echo can you tell
I've spelled that a few times
good morning my name is Kelly ludke I am
the board chair for the laidak board
um and I have been involved in the
laidak board
probably
um geez since 2011.
oh I'm sorry
um it's the board for Alcohol and Other
Drug use professionals
um so I've been involved with the board
for since about 2011
um but I'm testifying
as just a licensee as an m laidac in the
state because my board doesn't meet till
tomorrow so I didn't get a board vote
um I I'm going to keep this brief
I have a few things I guess I wanted you
all to know which is I wasn't even aware
of this bill until about four days ago
so that means I was never approached and
asked for my opinion on any of this
during the study committee so I felt a
little blindsided by it and
I want to say that I believe in a spirit
of collaboration of working together
and so the testimony that I prepared is
written I'm not going to go through each
of them I'll I'll submit this
um
but I feel like this bill really does
strip the authority of the laidac board
I feel that the oplc coming in because
when I first came on the board there was
no oplc we met at the Bureau of drug and
alcohol services and we did everything
ourselves
and it was cumbersome it was burdensome
it was difficult so when oplc came in
and they said hey Kelly we're going to
assign you a lawyer that you can consult
with I'm like wow this is great we're
going to assign somebody to do your
investigations great I love that it
really took a lot of Burden off the
board
however
I I don't believe at this time the oplc
is ready to take on
all of the administrative duties that
it's asking to do with repealing
so many of our state statutes
um one very quick example would be one
of the first laws they were trying to
repeal is the board not having the
authority to have a advisory committee
why what is the purpose of that we need
our advisory committee we have one
called the peer review committee and
they are essential
to getting our work done right now our
average board meeting begins at 8 A.M
and ends at about 5 to 6 pm
we're volunteers we all work full-time
jobs
if we didn't have our peer review
committee to review all new applications
for laidac and laidac crsw and LCS
we'd probably be there until midnight I
mean this this is an essential committee
to us and there's a lot there's um in
this bill they want to repeal us being
able to establish those advisory
committees that doesn't make any sense
to me there are other things where they
want to take our rights away our duty
our authority to conduct our own
investigations
right now
I I believe that our investigations
oftentimes need a person with expertise
to maybe work collaboratively on the
investigation
and I really think the work that the
oplc has been doing has been wonderful
I'm not here to say anything bad about
anybody except
I think we can work together I don't
think we need to repeal State statutes
to get the work done
um
I think there was some testimony around
this being streamlined because
there tends to be delays from the board
and frankly that kind of hit me in the
heart because I thought what I've given
investigation my cell phone number told
them to call me any time of the day with
any questions and anything they ever
needed
um
so that doesn't it doesn't feel accurate
to me I feel like there's a lot more to
say around each and every statue that
they're asking to repeal but again I'll
keep that
in written testimony
and I don't even know if I'm in
opposition of the whole bill I can only
say what I know about the laidac board
you know I don't know what every other
board does so I can't say I'm 100 in
opposition but I'm in opposition to
every single one of the state statutes
they want to repeal
for the late deck board
thank you thank you for your testimony
will you take questions
yes please any questions
thank you so much for your testimony
Kimberly Kirkland
foreign
good morning my name is Kimberly
Kirkland I'm a lawyer in Manchester and
I represent plaintiffs in medical
malpractice actions I'm also the
president-elect of the New Hampshire
Association for justice
um and I was a tenured member of the Law
School faculty at first at Franklin
Pierce and then UNH from 2000 to 2014
and during that time I taught two
courses which are relevant to what this
bill is trying to accomplish I taught
civil procedure which is the course that
teaches students the rules governing the
Civil process for adjudicating disputes
and I taught lawyer ethics and the
course about the lawyer discipline
system
I'm here today to talk specifically
about about how House Bill 655 relates
to the Board of Medicine and I'm
testifying in support of the the
legislation broadly and specifically
want to talk about why it will be
helpful in improving the functioning of
the Board of Medicine
as you all may be aware from the
articles in the Boston Globe and the
Manchester Union leader this summer
about a surgeon who had over 20
malpractice cases against him but had
had no action taken against him by the
New Hampshire Board of Medicine the
Board of Medicine is not functioning
well the globe Spotlight series looked
at the rates of attorney excuse me of
physician discipline across the country
and found that New Hampshire has the
lowest rate of new of a physician
discipline in the entire nation and with
respect to the surgeon who was the focus
of that Spotlight
investigation there was no other surgeon
in the country who had had as many
malpractice claims brought against him
so there's something wrong with how the
Board of Medicine is currently
functioning and I think when the folks
from the oplc were up here they
mentioned that the Board of Medicine has
actually been treated differently and so
the rules of the oplc the the rules that
this statute would apply would bring the
Board of Medicine process into
conformance with the process that's
applied to other boards and I think the
problem that has existed with a board of
medicine is really a result of the fact
that they've been treated differently
they've had a system where they from
start to finish have discretion
to police themselves and I think all of
us know all of us have had the
experience that it's hard to call a
colleague out it's hard to
say to a colleague or impose some
um
punishment on a colleague that's
something really difficult to do when I
was teaching at the law school I
remember teaching big classes 150
students and at time the time it came to
be doing the grading for a very
foundational course that was a real
screen for who was competent to become a
lawyer and who wasn't I was going to
need to fail people
and
my grading the grading at the law school
was anonymous
it was far easier for me to honestly and
objectively grade an exam when I didn't
know whose it was
and I think that's what this process is
going to bring to the Board of Medicine
it's going to take that original
screening the complaint will come in and
be handled by the office of professional
licensure and certification instead of
the medical review subcommittee of The
Board of Medicine which is where that
current initial screening happens and
the medical review subcommittee is a
committee made up of volunteers
Physicians it's a small committee and
they often don't have the expertise the
members of the committee don't have the
expertise to actually be evaluating the
conduct of the physician involved in the
complaint you might have a psychologist
looking at a Cardiology claim
um by bringing all of this into the oplc
having oplc uh do the first level of
screening bring in people with subject
matter expertise for that uh
investigation and then hand it to the
board of medicine for a determination of
whether it goes further and uh having
somebody a professional and unbiased
person from the oplc making a decision
about how best to prosecute that claim
in front of the Board of Medicine that's
an objective person kind of serving in
the role of the prosecutor of the claim
I think we're going to get better
outcomes from the Board of Medicine so
the
effort in this legislation to bring the
board of medicines processes into line
with those of the other boards will I
think improve the quality of the
evaluation of physician conduct that the
board has to undertake
I'd be happy to take questions thank you
so much any questions
yes representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman thank you for your
somewhat disconcerting testimony with
regard to the Board of Medicine but
um
and you've highlighted uh advantages in
the in the contemplated process of this
bill uh do you see any any deficits with
regard to some of the issues that have
been raised by previous Witnesses
I have not looked uh specifically at
issues relating to the psychology board
the social worker board or the board
relating to alcohol practitioners or
electricians but I would say that from
what I know of the board of medicines
um
processes I don't anticipate that there
would be issues with confidentiality
which is what came up and I think would
be you know of concern I didn't see
anything in the bill that made me think
that there was a risk of
um confidential information becoming
public that the board can still do
everything it would do now if it was
holding a public hearing to protect the
confidentiality of the patient making
the claim so that didn't seem like an
issue to me
yep follow up thank you so uh your
experience uh that you alluded to uh
your background uh would make you I
think a valuable member of the uh the
pool of of uh
of
um people involved in the subcommittee
workshop that we will be having on
Friday will you be able to be attending
at that as well I can do that yes thank
you
any other questions
sing none thank you very much all right
thank you very much
Stephen Rancourt ecba
good morning or afternoon no still
morning committee chair members my name
is Stephen ranquet I'm a licensed
electrician in state of New Hampshire
and I'm also the executive director of
the electrical contract is Business
Association I'm here representing them
as well
um I did take quite a bit of time to go
through the um the bill and make some
notes and I don't think you guys want to
hear it all right now so we'll probably
save that for some committee maybe I'll
get some brownie points for that
um I did have a few points that I wanted
to make and I'll kind of just put them
out there and then whether they want to
have some questions discuss them or go
to subcommittee we can do
um some of the concerns that have been
brought up or we we Echo as well the the
um concerns of allegations and
complaints
um just a brief brief little stories
talk what happened to me we have this
allegation to complaint we're concerned
about how it's treated if you just have
a standard and they don't have the
impact of the uh or consult from the
board or somebody because a complaint
was issued against me some years ago
they called up the state they complained
about me and they uh I got a call from
the state inspector
we discussed the situation I explained
to him and what happened is the customer
I was hired by a contractor I was
working for the contractor the
contractor did not call me back to go
and finish the electrical work because
he wasn't getting paid
the homeowner called the state and
complained and put an allegation against
me and I had to go and and protect and
defend myself and explain to him that
and we came to a compromise but you know
an allegation or a complaint has to have
some
um some Merit to it in the boards are
the most qualified to do that if you
start a process that just is here's what
we do ABCD it takes away that
information and that knowledge this was
simply about money he wasn't paying the
contractor and he was trying to force me
to finish and he went and had some other
people do some work the Well Company and
left a mess and they put that on my
complaint so just as an example there's
a lot more to it than just I file you
know somebody files a complaint if you
file a complaint on allegation and
it's not it's the board decides it
wasn't you weren't wrong you didn't do
anything what happens to all that
paperwork and information from
confidentially does it get expunged
stuff like that right so there's a lot
with that whole issue that's concerned
um without getting the input from the
board again which goes back to what
they're repealing the board's Authority
so to speak when they talk about
repealing the authority and there's
still plenty there yeah they're taking
all the meat and potatoes you know
they're just it's showpiece at this
point when you start taking half of this
away the rulemaking authority the fees
license renewal disciplinary action
hearings appeals investigations I mean
you know you can see what the board has
and the highlighted ones of what they're
taking away
provide that I'm sorry but so that needs
to be looked at a little better
um it's not a one size fit all fits all
for this
the
every word is different we've had pretty
good luck as our board not having some
of the issues that have been brought
forth to you and we think that it's
going to be difficult to do use the one
size fits all to to fix this completely
the confidentiality who has access to it
does every employee in oplc have access
to it how does that work and I'm sure
the people behind us can explain that
again these are just questions that
we're concerned about there's a lot more
employees in oplc than we used to have
on our board electricians board right we
had two one maybe two people who did the
admin
that's all that might have access to it
for us now is there a hundred people in
oplc that has access to all this or does
it stay under the investigations and
only a few people
um some concerns with the turnover and
just the because of the size of oplc had
a discussion with someone that the other
day that a couple weeks back they had a
meeting almost 50 percent of the
employees are new
what do they know about electrical
health profession medical and they're
processing this just based on this
agenda while we think the procedure in
trying to get consistent is important
there's got to be a fine line
um
balancing the the political and Justice
as well as the administrative Simplicity
as mentioned earlier is very important
um maybe breaking up into three sections
like representative emmentine mentioned
so that maybe some of the laws apply to
the three different sections and it's
still somewhat easy to administer
um fines are in there you know and
that's something new you talk about
three thousand dollars and fines for a
licensed electrician depending on but
they're not as stiff for the
non-electricians when they do an
investigation what do employees from the
oplc know about wire rating termination
or installation methods they don't but
they're going to determine whether this
is a just cause and then do we need to
hire somebody it's in there in the bill
they can hire somebody when our board
has the expertise with our state
inspectors we have licensed electricians
on the board and as many other boards do
um the
content expert again I think that our
board can provide that and don't
necessarily need to be hiring somebody
every time so those are some of the
changes and just again that it's you
know it seems like 10 10 of the boards
that are having problems are affecting
90 of the boards that don't and
hopefully we find a compromise in there
we don't disagree with the
administrative part and trying to make
it consistent and find some methods but
we feel that there's some middle ground
that needs to be addressed and uh we'll
conclude thank you for your testimony
any questions
yes representative
thank you Mr chair
I get exactly
what you're saying a little active
listening is that you're you're saying
that the Board needs to be part of that
process
and if there was something
added to say that an appointed board
member would ride the investigation with
oplc would that be
would that
make this better it would definitely
help I think we'd have to see the
wording because does it also talk about
from the very beginning of the
allegation you know with somebody you
know when my my particular situation the
state inspector Chief electrical
inspector is the one that called me I
explained to him the situation he
understood what was going on and he
simply asked me will you go take care of
that so we can just put it to bed so I
went back and finished it for free and
did stuff just to make it right but so
at the very beginning as well I guess
not just that during it
follow-up
I can absolutely understand why it's
essential to have somebody that's from
the field to help with that initial
investigation is any complaint that
comes through is not just a
plain
it's harassment it might be that I was
in your case
I was installing conduit two feet down
three feet away from the deck
oplc may not quite understand the full
complaint
is that what you're saying that's
correct without that expertise and those
employees that are taking that
information in don't have that yes
yes representative Gerhart thank you
chairman
making the complaint info public you're
against because it could be just
arbitrary but with online reviews these
days does that really matter I'm just
one especially electricians that say are
people just
are people doing some background before
they hire an electrician or the
contractor that's hiring them in their
subs that you they know who they're
hiring would you say I'm just wondering
if that's as much of a concern because
like with the hospital situation having
those complaints public somebody's going
for surgery is going to do whoa so I'm
just wondering if there's
thank you for the question I I think
that it varies based on the profession
or the because most electricians we're
not online we're working the customer
might go and look but honestly I don't
think they you know you can put good
reviews online we happen to know of an
electrician that lost his license and he
still you go online now he's advertising
someone else he's got all these great
reviews his license was revoked by the
state of New Hampshire and he's still
doing work so I don't know how much
weight it plays into it some people do
do the um diligent background and check
but I don't think a lot do so I don't
think the online part is going to show
that
you know my situation was put online or
something because that I mean he may
post something on there but
I don't know how it would affect
compared to having somebody involved to
make sure that it wasn't a just a
harassment type of situation
any other questions
thank you so much thank you
Deborah Warner
thank you so much I am so happy to be
here it is a privilege to be able to
testify I'm Dr Deborah Warner I'm from
Littleton New Hampshire I'm representing
myself and my practice Bright Day
psychology pllc
I um have been in practice in for
decades I have had occasions to work in
private practice in a non-profit agency
which I directed for more than 10 years
in the state system I worked for the GOC
and also youth
I also worked for the VA I've had a lot
of experience in different settings and
I've supervised many psychologists and
other mental health professionals along
the way I'm very well informed about
this legislation and also what led up to
it this legislation is 18 days old it's
just a little one come out of the
nursery
the I can say that the boys were not
consulted they it was not under
development in the study committee that
happened last year in September I regret
that I was not able to attend I had
coveted at that time
all better real good
um and so it was
um there were no board members or boards
represented on that committee or
testified on that there were no
professionals there were no professional
associations who testified in that study
committee it was you know all the
representatives and the senator and then
representatives from oplc that's who
came up with this and um and so it's
kind of uh one-sided I guess I'd say in
terms of whose perspective is
represented here I want to bring up some
points I am in full agreement with the
points made by the board of psychology
and I there are many more points as well
I I'm going to go over them globally and
correct some misunderstandings that seem
to have come about
um the
the privacy of medical records is not
really it was a
two years in the making with
representative Neil Kirk a dozen years
ago I was involved in that process I
don't that's how I got to meet this
board originally and
it's not about locks and Q you know keys
and security or about any of the
esteemed attorneys doing badly or
anything with leaking documents or
anything like that we have my port is a
very good attorney I appreciate how
disciplined he had at his work it's not
about that the privacy of your medical
records is that when you make a
complaint to the state about your
conditions of treatment whatever board
it was on
inside of that is the understanding and
also in the statute for the psychologist
it is exactly that when you do that you
are waiving your own privilege of
confidentiality on your own notes and
that they can be shared with the state
so that it can be evaluated
and that's important that makes sense
but if if you are subject of a third
party investigation let's say your
ex-spouse thinks that your psychologist
did a bad job because they divorced you
those records of your spouse or you
are then absconded they're taken to the
state
this
this point of this metal record this
privacy is that they cannot be taken
because they're a third party
they cannot
your records cannot be released without
your knowledge and consent
now the board in the process of an
investigation might say well we think
there's incompetence going on we need to
see a pattern across patients hey Dr so
and so give us 10 more patient records
this statute that was brought about
through a two-year process that involved
a house concurrent resolution
unanimously passed and bipartisan
legislation from the House and Senate
that was unanimously passed to protect
your records from being taken in these
third-party cases in
the the
expansion of an investigation that way
your records don't go somewhere to the
state without your knowledge or consent
and they don't end up in archives and
they don't end up looked at by people
that you you never even conceived of
I am a psychologist I take it seriously
people come to me with very precious
private issues it is an honor and a
privilege to help them in that space I
keep my mouth shut about that their
records are very secure I only release
them without their with their consent
and knowledge
and that's what is protected here it's
not that once any records come to the
state to for investigation that they
could be leaked it has nothing to do
with that
it has to do with you knowing and many
people here in the audience or even
among the Reps
might have gone to see a counselor I
might have told them private things I
don't think you would want those records
taken
without your knowledge or concern that
is the point of that it has nothing to
do with 91a it has to do with your
records going into the hands of the
state
I can say one of the things that
we do need to get things
that are operating and so on the
psychology board uh became independent
nine years ago
and in that time they've had 13
secretaries
and you wonder why there might be some
delays now and then they're
restructuring oplc is a brand new place
brand new Department they're
restructuring all the time they're
getting things more organized
they're developing it's a growing
evolving system which is fine they're
doing things
and we do need to do what we can but
this is as they said not one size fits
all and there does they're also I'm
going to take my glasses off so I can
see a little bit on here one of the
problems with this is in my first page
of my written testimony that you can see
that looks like this has my name at the
top Deborah Warner
is that
the investigation needs to be defined it
needs to happen when the as the way it's
written now when the allegation comes in
oplc just gets right to work in the
enforcement department and starts
investigating
that's the way it's written
that that's certainly There Are Rules
otherwise that we'll probably fall off
as their made congruent with what
they've written in their statute
but
you cannot have a
an un
defined investigation go on for a doctor
or any of the trades
that doesn't have charges in it
the the license is not even notified of
there's nothing in here that says they
have to be notified currently in our
statute the doctor gets notified
immediately when an allegation comes in
that's important and in fact they are
given an opportunity voluntarily to
respond
the board then looks at the allegation
side by side with the response and they
determine whether it violated the codes
and laws and rules
and whether or not it's trivial I mean
it might be nothing might be you don't
have enough Kleenex or something like
that
um
they can dismiss it they can say oh this
is an allegation we can say oh is this
serious we're going to investigate they
write an order of complaint and they
convert it from an allegation to a
complaint
and then they can Define that order of
complaint also to be an order of formal
investigation where they lay out the
charges to be investigated
those become the guard rails they the
scope of the investigation those are the
guard rails for the investigation team
then it goes over to enforcement and
they get to do that work that's missing
here
Reach Out
a person has a right a licensee has a
right to know something has happened and
that they've been complained about
it's as Dr Phillips said earlier it's
dangerous to not know if you're treating
mental health issues if somebody has uh
you know broken down and they're they're
making strange or even frivolous
um or or
unrealistic complaints about them the
psychologist
if the department says well this is just
crazy we're going to dismiss it and
we're not even going to tell the
psychologist that's psychologist it
doesn't know that their patient is
breaking down
that's unsafe for that patient it's
unsafe for the psychologist they need to
know immediately they're not going to be
mean they just need to know it's
important
there are some other things about that
bifurcated process between the
allegation and the complaint once it's a
complaint it is certainly reportable by
the doctor
to everybody that who asks that they
have a professional relationship with
among hospital privileges I've got
insurance panels I have my own practice
insurance there's medical societies and
such that all say do you have have you
ever had a complaint
but our statute
says if you have an allegation that's
not reportable and in fact insurance
companies and professional organizations
and institutions are prohibited from
asking about an allegation
that's going to be wiped out that's
going to be repealed
so there are things I understand that um
the reply from director Courtney was
that this is all 90 91a stuff and don't
worry everything's secure that has
nothing to do with it I walk out of
something and if I have a complaint or
an allegation I'm in a different status
for my whole profession and in fact if I
tell them that I've had an allegation if
I have to
because it's not protected by law if I
then have to tell them then I'm going to
be kicked off of insurance panels and
you know whole Realms of patients won't
be able to have reimbursement seeing me
I might still be licensed but I won't be
reimbursable
I might have an upgrade in my in
practice insurance I might not get
insurance
things like this will happen kicked off
of my hospital privileges all of these
things can happen because of that and
this is a protection in the law
currently
there are a
I can stop here
I will be here Friday there are so many
pieces of this I strongly urge the
committee to retain this bill it could
be good
I have had experience doing things like
this I will apply myself to this process
if you retain it you'll see a lot of me
in those subcommittees and I'm a good
worker as people know from my past so
um
have I clarified this thing about
patient privacy
that it's not a 91a issue
it's it's about
your medical records and where they go
and I've
okay thank you thank you for a testimony
well you'll take questions
any questions
uh yes representative gold
thank you Dr Warner and thank you for
coming down thank you representative
having worked with um child welfare
abuse and neglect allegations and the
intake process for that and trying to
consolidate that for the 13 different
districts around the state I am
I cannot imagine trying to do an intake
process a screening process for
complaints against so many different
um
disciplines and and be able to ferret
those out through a central office can
you talk about how you can Envision that
kind of a process happening in this case
well I think
badly yes
um I think that if if you know you have
a small Department of attorneys and they
have on occasion they draw in some of
the practitioners and they can call them
um and then they look that over
could be good but there's nothing in
this that says that they need to have a
professional of that practice involved
in any part of that investigation the
board would not know about an allegation
or a complaint until it's done with the
investigative process and then it comes
at them in a report
one other thing that does remind me as
well thank you for jogging my memory
once the board sees a report of
Investigation they then have uh the duty
to determine whether or not to take it
further and to do discipline
and they might recommend that there be a
settlement offered which is pretty
frequent from what I gather
at that point the licensee doesn't
hasn't seen anything
all they get is in this in this bill all
they would get is
an offer
with 20 pages long of well here you're
going to have restricted practice or
you'll be suspended for a year or you
have to do corrective supervision
whatever it might be and they've never
seen the allegation they've never seen
the evidence against them currently in
our statute before they were asked to
get into settlement negotiations they
would be given discovery
now a lot of us watch enough TV shows we
know what Discovery is and that's the
the other side gets to show what they've
collected that's relevant to the case
and it's in our statute right now that
when you as a doctor are being
approached for a negotiation you get to
see an accumulation of the evidence
that's been assembled against you
you don't get through legal analysis you
just get that and you get today and so
you can look at it and you can say well
it was so-and-so telling the truth well
I guess yeah they're saying it that way
and the board's taking it that way I I
guess I'll consider settling I'll talk
about it but if they look and say oh my
goodness this never happened
oh my goodness I wasn't even treating
them at that point or you know things
like that absolutely I'm gonna go to
hearing I'm gonna do that currently
actually
currently they get that report if they
didn't get the report after they might
choose to go to hearing then they would
get the regular kind of Discovery but
it's at that point where you're signing
away your occupation
that you you need that information it's
reasonable to do and in fact it's in the
law now I just
may I just say something yes I think
that this is also something that we can
talk about at the subcommittee hearing
I'm just you know concerned about the
time and I'm thinking that maybe this is
something we can talk about at the
subcommittee hearing on Friday okay I'll
say a closing comment then
thank you
um
when you are taking away rights and and
protections that are already in statute
you really need to justify why they're
taking that away
I think that's been misunderstood by
oplc unfortunately in their rebuttal but
that's I think if the onus is on them to
let us know why they could take that
away
thank you so much for your testimony
thank you very much
um that was the last pink card I had did
anybody else want to testify
foreign
would you mind turning your microphone
on
thank you
can you hear me okay yes thanks
uh good morning shangulay with the
office of professional licensure and
certification I'm here on the board on
behalf of the board of accountancy in a
very limited scope uh they met yesterday
and reviewed uh 655 and they wanted me
to bring this written testimony
specifically their concerns were General
in nature they want further review of it
and they expect further comments for the
subcommittee there are General concerns
relate to a central usurping of their
Authority as it relates to reinstatement
renewals rule making and the
investigative process I have the written
testimony here and I have no further
statements thank you great thank you so
much if you wouldn't mind just handing
it to the representative and pass it
around
would anyone else like to testify
seeing no one I will close the hearing
and
yeah I'll get you the card
and we are on recess until one o'clock
thank you
thank you for a kind of you
representative Susie how nice to see you
I didn't get a notice that you were
replacing representative Smith
I got one that that we were placing
representative Wilhelm but not uh
[Music]
all right well
if you say so I'll assume it's
legitimate but please send it to me
all right so we are on
our the plan for today is to
vote on
our early bills
and the first section of bills listed in
the notice are the early bills
um
the second group is bills that we have
heard but are not early but I'd like to
to
get as many of them out of the committee
as possible but we're going to start
with the early bills
and
let's see using ones first or hard ones
first
easy one
okay so let's start with House Bill 337
which is about notice of public meetings
and an opportunity to comment I believe
that went to the licensing subcommittee
all right
yes Matt and Cherry uh you should not
have
um Amendment
ah amendment number zero one eight zero
is that the one correct okay we have I
have that one
and I will first move that Amendment
this subcommittee
sorry
okay so you're moving on to pass with
Amendment 0180
okay so that is by schuette seconded by
leckis the committee heard during the
hearing that the sponsor learned that
the there was an incorrect RSA site
listed which unfortunately precipitated
the FM that's attached to the bill which
does not really apply once that RSA site
was corrected the amendment corrects
that RSA site to what you now see
310-a colon 1 hyphen d as in David
and then some of the language
in the actual first section of the bill
had concerns for oplc
that their confidentiality Clauses were
not properly protected
so oplc and the sponsor worked on the
language that you see in this amendment
and they're both happy with it the
sponsor feels that it allows the
transparency that he was seeking and the
better notice for public meetings
and oplc feels that the confidentiality
that they need is also protected
excellent representative thank you I
agree with all that I'll just expand a
little on the fiscal note issue I know
there was some people are concerned with
that what happened was they put it in
the section having to do with hearings
and disciplinary stuff which meant that
everything they were going to release
had to be reviewed by a lawyer which
meant they would have had to hire a
number of new lawyers and that was just
an error and this corrects that the
other concern o'plc had was in cases
where
something had to be dealt with in sort
of a not emergency but a short-term
basis and there's some allowance for
that here but I think it's a good
Amendment and and suggests we support it
does anyone else wish to comment on
House Bill
on the amendment to House Bill 337 which
replaces the entire build
so if we adopt the amendment the rest
that's all there is anyone else
good
thank you
all right in that case the motion is to
adopt amendment
0180h to house bill 337.
and the clerk and call the rule
representative Simon yes representative
Lucas yes representative Bailey yes
representative San Antonio yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative Bear yes
representative Gerhard yes the clerk
votes yes representative Broda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Hewitt yes representative O'Brien yes
representative massamilo
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative soucy
and the chair yes
and we got 20 a zero name
okay
no second as well okay
is there any further discussion
we covered it already in that case the
motion is ought to pass with Amendment
on House Bill 337 and the clerk can call
the rule
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo estaso
yes representative true
yes representative Dolan yes
representative a bear yes representative
Gerhard yes the clerk votes yes
representative yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative shewitt yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative massamila yeah
yeah representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould
yes
representative Susie
and the chair
and a vote 20-0
28 Journey all right one the vote is
20-0
and the objections to consent
yes seeing none will put it on consent
it is a fiscal note is it so we don't
the amendment calculates the expense and
I'm sure the committee report will make
sure to say so
okay speaking of that committee reports
are due today for anything we that we
can get in the calendar for next week
and I would appreciate if anyone that
makes a motion uh gets their committee
report in as quickly as possible
excellent sent
I like to see somebody prepared so yes
thank you that's a good idea
okay
um
let's do something
uh represent on House Bill 449
representative Goldie I believe you have
a motion
thank you madam chair uh I moved to
retain house bill 449.
sure
um
we have another bill that'll be coming
before this committee dealing with uh
this issue and that being Hospital
436 that has an amendment that
subcommittee will be hearing I think
that
takes care of the issue we're looking at
so therefore until that bill goes
forward and is taken care of that I
think to retain it is the appropriate
thing to do
yes thank you we'll
it'll be good to have something in case
the Senate makes major changes to our
bills or something like that
so okay any further discussion
all right seeing none the motion is to
retain house bill 449.
it's look and call the roll
foreign
yes
representative lakis yes representative
Bailey yes representative Santo nastasso
yes representative true yes
representative Dolan yes representative
yes representative Gerhard yes the clerk
will Jess representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes
representative shewitt yes
representative O'Brien
yes representative massamila
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould
yes representative Susie
and the chair yes
28-09
all right thank you and representative
goalie you are fortunate no report is
needed on a routine recommendation
uh so that leads us to House Bill 436
thank you madam chair
um we received late yesterday uh an
amendment that representative Pearson
has put a lot of work into it completely
overhauls 436 as it stands and we need
an extra day of committee subcommittee
work to to look at that we'll bring it
back to you next week
okay the
the or next Wednesday okay I will I'll
check with my subcommittee members and
okay see what their availability is we
need that's it's an important bill and
we need to get to work on it so we will
re recess the exact session until
either Friday yeah my only concern with
Friday is I know people wanted some time
to look at it and it's a fairly
substantial
um Amendment
well we'll we'll decide by the end of
the day today when we will do that
uh it will be no later than next
Wednesday because that is absolutely
positively the last minute
that's that one
we know whether representative Pearson
is going to be able to facilitate that
would you care to share that with US
Representative
Friday morning or Wednesday morning of
next week
um no when the subcommittee can meet
that's the question
Wednesday unfortunately we do have a
fairly low we do have scheduled public
hearings so you would want to have it
ready to exec on Wednesday
is it possible for the subcommittee to
meet after this exact session since the
subcommittee can meet after this they
24-hour notice
does a continuance of a work session
require notice since it was 24 hours
yeah it does right
this is not a work session
I'm sure you can find a room on Monday
or Tuesday if you need to but and like I
said Friday morning is available
I know for sure that the rooms are
available because no other committee is
meeting on Friday okay so you can have a
room all day
okay
all right then
I'll spill 250. representative Simon
thank you madam chair I
um we'll move itl on HB 250.
is there a second
Fitzpatrick okay
uh do you wish to speak to your motion
yes
um my apologies to the committee this
actually came out of the subcommittee
all to pass 3-2 I was the deciding vote
on that since that time I've gained a
better understanding of the bill I
missed the original public hearing
my understanding right now is that if an
officer or is anybody in group two dies
um
they receive 50 of a year salary a
hundred thousand dollars out of the
general fund and they're still still
have their regular uh retirement package
accessible as it always would
um obviously we can't put a monetary
value on somebody giving their life and
I wouldn't even pretend to try to do
that our gratitude goes out to those
those people
um but we do have to make decisions
practical decisions as well and I feel
like that's uh
we are honoring them with the package
that we're that we're offering
foreign
Patrick
do you wish to speak to your second
true oh
excuse me gentlemen my mistake
I've forgive me I I have nothing to add
to uh to the comments already made
representative
so I just want the community to know
that this only is in is um
um I will not support the motion of itl
and I will say that this only
um represent people who pass away only
get paid if they die
so let's hope that doesn't happen
it's representative goalie
thank you madam chair and I too will be
voting against us I think we heard
testimony that
if someone retires and chooses the
benefit that allows their surviving
spouse to get a hundred percent
that option is available
so once that person is passes away and
dies that the spouse continues to
receive a hundred percent this goes
backwards and says that
if someone is killed in the line of duty
the spouse only receives 50 of that
benefit versus the hundred percent if
so I think it was a matter of fairness
that we heard
and it codifies a statute that allows
100 percent
going forward upon the accidental death
while in duty of service so I cannot
support the Ito
representative blackis and then O'Brien
um yeah I had some initial confusion
about that my understanding and if it's
incorrect and the chair wants to ask Mr
Carland to make it clear we can do that
but I believe that those are two
completely different things that this
bill is
raising the one-year amount they get
if they die from 50 to 100 with the on
top of the hundred thousand that's there
but
um if they're retired they can get a
hundred percent but that
um that's a selection by the person who
retired and they're paying for that by
accepting lower uh pension payments at
least that's my understanding so
I initially had similar thoughts as to
what represent goalie said but I don't
think that's how it works it we're
talking about 50 or 100 percent of two
different numbers
this would raise the
total value of the
this would make the amount that this
Widow would receive
to be up from 50 to 100 percent of their
annual rate of earnable compensation
which is not the same as the amount of
pension that would have been earned
that's what it says a hundred percent of
the manuals rate vulnerable compensation
is that not correct representative bully
it's the state annuity so it's the full
term of the
payment
going out right so it's 100 going
forward right same thing that if a
member chose the 100 option upon
retirement at their death that their
spouse receives a hundred percent it's
100 option which many do the amount they
get is not the same as their annual
compensation it's the amount of their
pension lowered to to make it for two
lives instead of one
Mr Carlin if you could uh help us with
our terminology here thank you
I'm getting confused and I'm sure I'm
not the only one
thank you madam chair for the record
Marty garland from New Hampshire
retirement system so the question is
what what the current accidental death
benefit for a group two member who who
is uh killed uh in a job related
incident the surviving spouse would get
50 percent for life of the members you
know last year of earnable compensation
so whatever their current rate of uh
earnings were 50 of that as a lifetime
benefit plus a refund of the members
accumulated contributions towards the re
you know towards their own retirement
you know the money that they were
putting in over the years before the
incident so that this bill would
increase that to 100 of the you know the
last year's earnable compensation and
the lump sum piece stays in there is a
payout the hundred thousand dollar death
benefits your reference is a separate uh
appropriation outside the retirement
system that's a general fund
um provision
okay
but at retirement if the member were to
select the 100 option just for
simplicity's sake the amount that he got
would not be necessarily equal to his
last
Year's earnable compensation is that
correct correct I mean it you know if
the you know the last year was in the
high three or the high five it would be
you know a friend you know a portion of
that but uh you know when a benefit is
um calculated is What's called the
maximum option which is the benefit is
paid to the retiree for their lifetime
and and as as discussed there's
something called the survivorship option
where the member can make a choice at
retirement to leave some or all of their
pension to uh one or more individuals
um you know there's some statutory
limitations on who can give that to and
and if you're leaving a survivorship
option uh there is a reduction in the
monthly benefit from the outset
um related to the so basically based on
the age of the member and the age of the
beneficiary uh you know it's sort of a
life expectancy calculation
okay
so that the fact that this benefit is
100 of or fifty percent of earnable
compensation is not necessarily related
to what the pension would be even at 100
Survivor benefit correct it is there's a
little bit of a variation in the statute
the group one accidental death benefit
is 50 of their average final
compensation the group two is fifty
percent of their you know um current you
know annual rate of compensation that
you know I'm
not sure how much more different that is
for some people but you know it is set
up differently in the statute already
I'm not sure what the history on that is
okay so that the maximum pension would
be 50 of
earnable compensation for
last three years or whatever and that
would be reduced to allow for it to
continue Over The spouse's life as well
as or the beneficiary's life as well as
the with the service retirement yeah yes
yeah okay there's no age-based
reductions or anything in the the death
benefit okay thank you representative uh
O'Brien you had a question
thank you madam ships
um by going judging by your questions uh
first I'm not going to support this
obviously but I do agree with
representative Cooley and what he said
but it seems to be the focus in the
questions is at the end of the career
I'm more concerned at the beginning of
the career we were all young men all
young ladies once and we know our
financial obligations at that particular
time we were in a very critical moment
we went out and purchased houses cars
different things and we're blessed with
children along the way and had those
other expenses that came up but most of
the contractual stipulations and
departments you work in a tiered
environment for every single year you
come on at probably probation every rate
of pay like I say and then you work
yourself up to basically TOP Step so if
you had it were a firefighter on
probation
married with children and were killed in
the line of duty you're talking to Mia
pittance
but this and that's going to put that
family into a financial strain and this
is the reason why this bill came forward
it is it's talking about fortunately a
very rare event
that occurs okay it's not like we lose a
firefighter a mouth or a police officer
a month if you did who wouldn't want to
work those jobs you know it's very
difficult so in the rare cases as it
does happen it protects at all
yes it will protect the guy that's at
the high end closer to retirement but
don't forget about the young guy
that is trying to start the family he's
at the weakest
financially at that particular time and
needs our protection so I am not going
to support this Bill thank you Matt
Madam chair and may I have a question of
the chair please it seems with
additional information do you think we
would want more time to digest Mr
Collins remarks or do you want to have
the vote stand well I'm because there's
a couple of people that have already
wanted signed up to speak so we'll let
them talk okay thank you madam chances
to uh
pause on this we can do that
representative a bear
thank you madam chair
it would it would be my sentiment to
have a little bit more time on this
based on the confusion among the
committee and my own confusion thank you
all right thank you representative
shuitt
thank you madam chair I don't know if he
knows the answer to this but I'm curious
if Mr Carlin could give us an idea of
approximately how often this kind of
thing happens on the job
um I I can if I went back to my chair
and looked on my phone I could I could
find out exactly in a couple of minutes
I I off and I will do that after I leave
this this seat and wave my hands if I'm
wrong but I believe there's currently
about somewhere in the vicinity of 20
group 2 job related death benefits being
currently paid to to survivors at this
point I think it's you know 19 or 20 or
something like that but if I'm way off
I'll wave my arms but I'm pretty pretty
sure that's what we're what the current
landscape is this would not be
retroactive though those those people
what I'm what I'm my question was is if
you have a a sense and I know it's not
totally accurate how often we lose one
of these people on the job okay I I
don't have a strong sense I mean
typically when something a tragedy like
that happens you know it does get news
coverage and I can certainly recall you
know you know more than more than a
couple in recent years but I don't have
a count maybe
um you know somebody else with one of
the employer a member organizations has
has a better idea of the incidence of
this but um you know it it happens sadly
but rarely yes representative a bear
thank you madam chair
may I suggest on all future
retirement bills that there be a graph
that's not
like the graphs that we get perhaps you
should talk to the retirement system Mr
Carlin is the person involved thank you
may I talk directly to Marty yes Marty
going forward right now oh sorry
yes I can express your frustration with
some of the data information we get it's
not always the best Mr Widow I'd like to
say this is not a public hearing we are
not taking testimony from the committee
from from the public it is purely a
discussion in the committee to vote on
the bills
we might ask as in this case someone
that has special knowledge but we are
not taking testimony
the public hearing was a while ago on
House Bill 180.
all right
um any other questions representative
Simon thank you madam chair I'm in a bit
of a awkward quandary at the moment
because after Mr Carlin's testimony it
this is closer to what I thought it was
initially than what I was led to believe
secondarily so I don't really support my
own motion
um
well that's a very awkward situation
it's an awkward situation for me to be
in and just offer acceptance if I'm
allowed to withdraw my motion I would
like to do so withdraw your motion
minutes and go on to the next bill
this uh
offer accepted
offer accepted okay thank you
all right
okay so house bill 371.
well let's finish the retirement house
bill 571.
Simon that do you have a motion on that
yes I move in expedient to legislate
manager
okay is there a second
is there a second on itl for a second
okay
do you care to speak to your motion uh
yes Madam chair thank you
um as I stated in the subcommittee
um this year 436 has got to be our our
main priority and focus and it's going
to be quite expensive
um a lot of people are finding
themselves where they're in their
they're in group two or not they're
finding themselves in precarious
situations financially uh due to
inflation
um and I don't want to force people who
are not in group two who are in
precarious situations to pay extra taxes
um for this at this particular point in
time
um so for those reasons I move and
experience legislate all right
you'd like to speak to your second
oh yeah no further comment thank you
what I don't uh everything you said was
great okay
all right does anyone else wish to speak
representative they bear and then Goldie
thank you I support this motion but I
want to make it clear why I do
that I truly believe that 436 needs a
lot of work as representative Simon
indicated and that I
am hesitant to push through too much and
have us lose everything
we know how contentious this has been
year over year over year and I think our
Focus needs to be on 436 it is not my
intention to put retired firefighters
over retired firefighters and police
over
active firefighters and police
that is not what this is about
thank you
okay other represent goalie
thank you madam chair and let me try and
win over representative Simon one more
time
no to be honest
um
I cannot support the itl motion
um we are a policy committee not a money
committee that is to be done in finance
and I think the true policy here is
whether or not those retirees uh deserve
a cost of living adjustment
we have to remember group two members
do not pay into Social Security
well that is for the jobs they're
working as police fire or Corrections
some may have a side job and pay social
security on the other end but when they
go to collect that Social Security
they're getting it at probably 70
percent of what they're entitled to
because of what is called the windfall
present um windfall Act that doesn't
allow them to collect the full amount of
Social Security they pay into
group one members pay both Social
Security and retirement they're able to
collect on the cost of living
adjustments that were just handed out
this year by the federal government and
group two employees don't see that so
to stay up with the economy and as we
all see cost of living increases in our
food heating oil gas prices
um I look at this as going forward
a policy issue that this committee needs
to address how it's funded or whether
it's funded I believe belongs in finance
so I'm not going to support the ITIL
thank you thank you
representative O'Brien and then
no Brian okay thank you madam chip I uh
I am not going to support this and yet I
agree totally to what uh representative
goalie has said but to come up with his
own uh when I sit in this chair
I try to judge as best as I possibly can
without fear and favor and not
intimidated by any other committee
that is not up to me to judge that what
another committee is going to do when as
you know as Representatives when we
write a bill we hand a bill over to the
committee it's no longer our bill
it becomes a property of that committee
and they make that particular decision
on what they want to adjudicate on as
far as their decision we are a policy
committee
okay and with deep respective
representative Simon I understand
sometimes you can go to the well too
much in the gorgeous help with water you
can ask too many times I completely it's
a well-thought idea but then that's
ruling by fear and favor because what
would happen is all it seems in the past
that I'm not pointing any blames but
this particular group has been very a
lot of mileage in years since the last
time they received a cost of living
increase if the time isn't right now
then I gotta ask you the proverbial
question is next year correct
or the year after
when are we gonna you know find out when
the proper time is going to be so the
thing is this is why we have our former
government where the policy committee we
should push this forward to the next
committee which would be financed and
allow them to determine if they can
afford this if they cannot we'll write
back to where we are in the in the
position of itl my recommendation is
that to change the vote and go for ought
to pass to assist the people who
dedicated their lives to their own
respected communities
many years ago so thank you madam chair
thank you madam chair
thank you representative O'Brien for
that testimony
I'd like to take a different tact on
this
my concern is that we're both what we're
doing if we go forward with this and
just OTP it we're pitting one group of
seniors against another group so in my
town Northfield there's 65 I believe it
was seniors that are applying for
property tax exemptions well waivers for
the um interest fees because they can't
pay their property taxes and I'm just
worrying that by benefiting this group
now we're going to be putting them in
danger of losing their homes so my whole
issue is inflation's coming from the
federal government why aren't we dealing
with that at that level and I believe
there's mechanisms that we can do so for
instance there's a dollar per pack it's
actually 101 per pack of cigarettes
there has to be some mechanism why we
can say where we can say okay you know
what we're tired of sending you money
because obviously you're just deflating
our currency as it is that's my whole
position on that I I'm just worried
about pitting one group against another
group one real our real problem is who's
praying the money like it's going out of
style
uh thank you and Madam chair this is not
going to be a debate I respect the
gentleman's uh point of view but from my
experience as vice president on the
board of aldermen we do give out elderly
exemptions okay but that liability
you know that isn't a gift from City
Hall
that is met by somebody else and in in
this particular case yes it would be met
but the thing is this is people uh if I
had my most idyllic world and
fortunately you're a young fella you're
not ready to cross that elderly bridge
yet and God bless you for that but the
point I'm trying to make is as you get
older your spending power are
receivables decreases okay and when if
you're on a defined benefit program such
as this which the guy most of the
firefighters and group two employees do
not get the social security so they're
not getting the bump up at that
particular time so they're frozen in
time you might as well and Cake them in
nice
okay and they are going to be the
problem in the community because what's
going to happen at some point without a
cola they're going to become less means
to be able to afford their housing
they may be kicked out of their
particular housing might be defaults
worst case scenarios can happen when you
have no other means of income you've got
to tell an 80 year old guy to go out and
get a paper rope I I choose not to
presenting a very extreme position
representative Simon
thank you madam chair and uh
representative O'Brien the respect is is
absolutely Mutual
um I just want to clarify I'm not making
an argument simply based off of money
and whether or not we should be spending
the 82 or 84 million dollars that this
bill is asking us to spend my contention
with it is that
when the members of group 2 agreed to
their defined benefits package they were
agreeing to a package and that package
did not include a yearly Cola
um it didn't it didn't agree to a cola
at any point in the future so from my
perspective this is a policy decision in
which I
fully uh sympathetic to the difficult
situations that we all find ourselves in
as we get older
um group two members are no different
than that but neither are any other
citizen
um in the state and because the benefit
package did not include a cola
I don't feel that we're under obligation
to favor them because at that point we
are it wasn't in their benefits package
we're favoring them over other people
and those other people are the ones who
are going to be footing the bill for
this so all of the examples that you
just gave in your testimony
um can be applied to people outside of
group 2.
and once again furthermore because of
the way that we fund this
those other people who can find
themselves in the same situation are
then going to be taxed more in order to
pay for this benefit and so it's it's
not a in my perspective from that's that
is a policy issue I am making that
determination on a policy issue and
that's why that's the primary reason why
I'm moving itl I could I could stomach
the 84 million if you know like if it
was a good enough reason
um it's a policy thing that's got me
concerned
okay
representative goalie thank you madam
chair and just to address the cost of
living adjustment Marty correct me if
I'm wrong was there not a supplemental
account that provided some colas
previously
in the retirement system or what's the
history of that answer that question
there was a cola there was a a special
account that funded cost of living
increases but the money that went into
it was only made available by
inaccurate and in hindsight foolish
Actuarial assumptions
if I may respond but there was colas
being provided which we just heard there
were not and when the people signed up
but there were colas that were provided
yes there have been cost to living
increases granted periodically through
since the retirement system was founded
absolutely right anyone I would like to
comment that I think the approach to
this bill by
specifying only group two members
is
divisive and somewhat discriminatory and
I understand why you did it because it
is somewhat a supplement to Social
Security but I think that the approach
is
um
is bad policy in my opinion
so I'm going to be supporting the motion
anyone else
yes representative O'Brien
you tweaked my melon that I got for her
years that I was born with if if Madam
chair if you feel that way are you in
essence saying that maybe we're going
around this the wrong way and maybe this
bill could be held in work for further
amendments that that you feel that any
uh way to go it because we are talking
about a very very important issue and
supplementing the income of some of uh
less fortunate who only sin is
by the time
yes well I would wouldn't say that
that's their only sin
uh I'm old I'm retired and I know that
when I was working I had a defined
benefit pension and I looked at it and
said I'm not going to be able to live on
this
and so I took steps to make sure I had
other funds available and I would not
insult the intelligence of our police
and firefighters to say that they
couldn't have realized that themselves
and taken similar steps
and the same for our group one employees
I mean we all all of us retirees were
working in the late 70s and early 80s
when inflation was rampant
we we know that it can happen
so if we didn't take steps we are
gambling on the charity and the mercy of
the legislature
to to give us money and to charge our
friends and neighbors for it
that's that's my position on the policy
follow-up follow-up
that's your position so there's no
saving of this
that you can see we'll see what the
committee decides I'm not the only one
with the position thank you madam chair
all right anyone else
representative Dolan yes uh thank you
madam chair I just would encourage you
to move the question
what's that I would just encourage you
to uh
uh thank you we can't do that in
committee debate in committee executive
session cannot be cut short for any
reason
except of course lack of Interest by the
other members when they uh
that's the only reason all right
anyone else representative a bear
so could I just get clarification before
the vote was there a cola and then there
wasn't a cola and now we're trying to
put a cola back in no ever since the
retirement system
started there have been various
increases given in pensions sometimes
one-time payments sometimes complete
colas they were always ad hoc and at the
will of the legislature they are not in
the plan there's no money saved up for
them and they are not guaranteed
so there there have been many cases in
the past where colas were given
but again they they're not in the plan
representative thank you uh possible
um
clarification of Representative Aver's
question the last term there was a
one-time payment that was made to
retirees but it was only to those who
made thirty thousand dollars or less
in most cases group 2 retirements are
slightly more than that however so they
were not included because it was capped
at that amount and it was a one-time
only payment
and
um most of the group two retirees
probably make around 40
000 maybe 50 000 in retirement but don't
get anything added to that in the way of
Social Security bear that in mind so
they were basically excluded from that
one-time payment
thank you madam chair yes that is
correct anyone else
okay in that case the motion is
inexpedient to legislate by
representative Simon and the clerk can
call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
lakis yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative a bear yes
representative Gerhard yes
clerk vote Jess Representative groda no
representative Schmidt no
Representative shewitt no
representative O'Brien no
representative massamila
representative Davis no
representative Fitzpatrick you know
representative Gould no
representative Susie
and the chair
yes
we got 10 yay ten nay the motion fails
on a tie
uh Madam chair yes
move ought to pass
on houseboat 571 all right ought to pass
by representative Goldie is there a
second
oh second
Goldie seconded by representative Broda
do you wish to speak to your motion
I think I've said enough um it's just a
matter of this has been given in the
past and
these folks do not receive cost of
living adjustments through Social
Security and
I'll leave it at that okay representing
no no comments thank you all right does
anyone else wish to speak
all right in that case the clerk can
call the roll
representative Simon no
representative Lakers no
representative Bailey no
Representative santoso no representative
true no representative Dolan no
representative a bear no representative
Gerhard no
the clerk votes no
representative groda yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative shewitt yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative massamilo
representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
soucy yes
and the chair no
all right that motion fails on a 10-10
tie unless I've counted wrong
yes
therefore we will send this to the house
with no recommendation representative
Simon you will write the statement in
favor of itl and represent a goalie in
favor of ought to pass
um
we can do that today that we can have an
interesting debate next week
okay
it's no recommendation
all right
moving away from pensions for a moment
uh House Bill 341 establishing licensure
from established athletes representative
Santa mustasa uh make a motion itl for
341.
oh
okay
I do wish to speak to your motion
yes uh 341 uh it looks like the intent
to establish licensing for massages is
to prevent uh sex trafficking
um and I don't believe that this is
gonna solve the problem uh the um it's
kind of uh we already have like law
enforcement to look into these things
and produce warrants to enter
establishments and uh the
misdemeanor for not registering uh is
that's not going to be enough incentive
for people to to either just continue
doing it without a license they're not
gonna comply with this if they are
actually doing uh having a sex
trafficking operation they're not going
to go ahead and get licensed so they can
business can be looked into so I don't
think it's gonna uh help
representative Gerhard
thank you madam chair
going back to the original testimony on
this bill
there was a massage
masseuse who submitted testimony that
she contacted the police for
propositions of Performing services that
are extracurricular in the field and the
police weren't interested as well as the
fact that local police we were told were
not enforcing ordinances they just
didn't feel his priority so if local
entities are not concerned with this I
don't see the point in having the state
step in
thank you
excuse me I'll be voting against the itl
motion in testimony the bill was brought
forth because other businesses are also
licensed such as the pharmaceutical
board and other similar boards and this
is not a law enforcement
proposition this is a public safety bill
and lastly I do have an amendment to
House Bill 341 which I can introduce at
a later time so I'll be voting against
the itl motion thank you
uh I'd like to comment that a
substantial portion of the regulated
Community was opposed to the bill which
is generally a red flag for imposing a
new license
uh
they may have been organized by a group
outside the state representative Schmidt
but they are in fact New Hampshire
businesses and they are they are working
here they're licensed by the board of
massage therapists and they don't want
to have this additional license imposed
on them I'm very much concerned that we
are
putting restrictions on our small
businesses in order to make it easier
for law enforcement to Target some of
the bigger ones that are uh that are the
bad apples
and that's something that I don't think
is right I'm also very concerned that
we're
willing to use our
licensing organization as law
enforcement I can't imagine
getting your license CL somebody from
the oplc saying hi I'm here from the
oplc please show me your your licenses
into a sex trafficking operation
I mean
that's
a very unsafe position to put those
people into
representative Dola
thank you madam chair I'll be voting uh
in favor of the itl
um
but I'm uh I am concerned that this that
the state is not doing enough to stop
human trafficking
okay thank you other comments
representative Bailey
I I think there's been some kind of
mistake I mean this is not a licensing
function this is some kind of law
enforcement function and if you have any
doubt of that there was a parade of
police officers all the way up to
Homeland Security testifying in favor of
this and not a single masseuse or
massage parlor and a proprietor or
um
with apologies to Sherlock Holmes it's
not the function of Licensing to supply
the deficiencies of the official police
thank you okay anyone else
representative Schmidt
well we're capitulating in in the face
of uh a clear public nuisance a public
anti-safety situation uh when we had
people from uh one of the towns that
indicated uh that they were having a
major problem with this and there's
something like 35 or 40 of these
establishments uh so if you're going to
talk about law enforcement the reality
is it's only a misdemeanor uh and so
it's it really isn't worth the police's
time to bounce somebody who can they get
their uh fine paid they get shipped out
of town they get replaced immediately
the operation goes on and the police
feel completely frustrated and their
inability to have a positive impact on
this uh and so to the degree that the
legitimate therapeutic massage
practitioners
[Music]
are in some cases even being conflated
with these illegal sex traffickers is is
something that uh was was used to uh in
my opinion uh improperly influence the
people we heard from a very small number
of people by the way the practitioners
so
um
if we are going to do nothing then we
might as well go home but I ain't going
home I'm voting against this and I'm
going to continue to try to get us to do
something responsible to for the
communities that are being plagued
Dairy four or five of these places
Merrimack four or five of these places
for a total of about 40 in the state of
New Hampshire and we are doing nothing
but we could be doing something
perhaps we should be making it more than
just a misdemeanor so that the local
police are incentivized to take stronger
action would representative Gould and
then Simon
thank you madam chair I
I don't see this I mean I hear the
testimony breaking down on the
bipartisan lines and for me it's very
important to take a look at who it is
the policy should be helping
and I did not hear from
hardly the few massage par power
therapists I heard from were opposed to
it and so
um
though it may be very unpopular I am
going about to support the Ito
thank you representative Simon thank you
madam chair I would just like to say I
don't think that this is an issue of us
capitulating
um
I hate human trafficking I hate sexual
human trafficking I am more than happy
to fight on every reasonable front to to
stop that practice from happening but I
think we should be honest about what
we're doing and oplc has a lot of
inspectors in a lot of different areas
they go in to make their inspections
for a reason and a purpose and that is
so that the public is safe specifically
regarding the service that they're
providing and I don't really want
um
oplc investigators coming into my
business as a as a convenience store
Deli looking for money laundering
um I feel like that that is a Law
Enforcement issue I don't think oplc is
uh because they're not law enforcement I
don't think they're in a position to do
that safely that is not their area of
expertise if we can come up with another
solution to this that that does go
primarily in the law enforcement
Direction Mr meaner in my opinion is
ridiculous and that needs to be adjusted
I'm happy to work on that I'd be happy
to to um
be a prime sponsor on a bill like that
but I think that this approach is
dishonest
um I think it muddies the water too much
and I think it puts people at risk that
shouldn't be at risk and in order to
solve this problem
there's no dishonesty in this bill and
there's no dishonest intent
and I am offended by that
this bill is a licensing bill for Public
Safety and it allows the inspection of
massage establishments just like we
allow inspections of hairdressers
cosmetologists estheticians anybody who
is serving the public so please let's
stick to the subject
yes thank you thank you representative
Broda we you can't know why someone is
doing something and it is
thoroughly improper to attack their
motives
the effects yes but not their motives
so
if I may I had no intention of doing
that and I didn't even realize that I
had so I sincerely apologize that's not
the way that I meant for her to come
across representative
thank you any other comments questions
yes representative Gould
I just want to follow up that I really
appreciate the intent of Representative
Grody on this bill and others that
worked really really hard on it and
um and I support a hundred percent that
the bill got
um
hijacked by this whole sex trafficking
and what I found particularly offensive
was the whole issue became focused on
one minority group and we know that who
work in the field that the problem is
much bigger so I support representative
grody's efforts but
the way the bill got presented in the
hearing I cannot support it
thank you anyone else
okay
seeing none the motion is inexpeding to
legislate on House Bill 341 by
representative Santa anastasa then the
clerk can call the rule representative
Simon yes representative Lagos yes
representative Bailey yes representative
santoso yes representative true yes
representative Dolan yes representative
yes representative Gerhard yes
clerk will Jess Representative groda no
representative Schmidt no
representative goalie no
Representative shewitt no
representative O'Brien
no
representative massamilo
representative Davis no
representative Fitzpatrick no
representative Gould
yes
representative Susie
and the chair yes
and get a vote 11 yay nine nay
okay the most passes a little to nine I
don't believe we should go for consent
uh representative Broda do you wish to
write a Minority Report yes okay so
grota will write a Minority Report
okay
foreign
[Music]
House Bill 620 representative is sure
why you had a motion
representative has a motion yes
um to move uh itl on hb620
for a second
okay
do you wish to speak to your motion I do
um first of all from the the Edna point
of view I think um
the idea of standing up a whole separate
department for the purpose of a
basically a pilot program is a very
strange odd and inappropriate one
and I've heard there's some discussion
about maybe
amending it to change that maybe put it
into the doe or somewhere else and my
issue with that is
I mean the question or whether or not
that's a good idea
is not one that I think is appropriate
for Edna I mean that's an education
question
and that should go to that committee and
if people want to do that they could
there could be a bill
that would address that separately
without trying to stand up a whole
department just for that
and uh on a somewhat not serious note I
wouldn't want to step on my wife's uh
uh feet or toes on taking over education
bills
all right thank you
representative Sasser do you wish to
speak to your second
uh I concur with uh Tony Lucas's
comments okay
representative Broda
thank you so there was a subcommittee
meeting on House Bill 620
and the Department of Education attended
the subcommittee meeting
and there were three subcommittee
members there myself
representative Wilhelm and Mr
representative Center nastazo
and a an amendment was discussed because
the department of education does want
this under their jurisdiction
and the amendment was written so that
the
Department of Education would have it
would establish a division not have a
separate Department therefore
I would encourage the committee we can
do two things we can continue obviously
on the vote but I also would like to
suggest that the subcommittee which did
not look at this
um
Amendment and you can meet again with
all its members present
could take a look at it and comment on
the sub on the amendment to the
committee thank you but I will not
support an itl motion
thank you
comments questions
I I'd like to say myself that I attended
part of that subcommittee meeting and
it seemed to me that the department
that there wasn't much of a need for a
bill
the at the 10 at the hearing the Depo
the board of education for Manchester
spoke in favor of this but they already
have a
pilot program very similar as far as I
could tell to what this bill would
create
and so I don't see the need for us to
get involved
and I'm also very much against forming a
new division or a department
for something that I'm not convinced is
actually a state responsibility
so that's my position
representing a bear and then Groton
thank you madam chair
I will be
I will be supporting itl against HB 620
FN
for the one fact that during testimony
what we heard is arpa funds were used to
establish this pilot in Manchester and
I ran on Lower taxes
and don't believe that anything used
with anything with any arpa fund should
be a one-time thing and done and this is
growth of the education department so I
am voting itl thank you
representative
anyone else
okay if you don't wish to say anything
then the motion isn't expedient to
legislate by representative leckis and
the clerk can call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
Lucas
yes representative Bailey yes
representative santosasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative yes
representative Gerhard yes
the clerk votes yes
Representative no representative Schmidt
no
represent goalie no
Representative shuitt no
representative O'Brien no
representative massimillo
representative Davis no
representative Fitzpatrick no
representative Gould no
representative soucy
and the chair
yes
and we got 10 years no no 10 and 10. 10
I'm sorry ten ten I'm sorry
it's quite all right I'm a little
flushing all right the motion fails on a
tie representative Broder you have
another motion I do I move an amendment
number
um 2023
0376 and I can distribute that to the
committee now and the bill
um do you have do we have copies of that
Amendment right here okay if you could
pass that around yep and meanwhile does
someone wish to second the motion
okay thank you
thank you
foreign
so the amendment creates a division this
was this amendment was written in
conjunction with um the representative
from the Department of Education during
the subcommittee meeting
and um representative Heath the bill
sponsor was also there
and this bill creates a division of
Early Education in the Department of
Education and it's whether or not we all
believe we all think of when education
starts there's a start Pre-K or does
occur we're in kindergarten to start
when you're in first grade when did you
think children
um
should be begin their their formal
education
um the um it's a pilot program so it's
not something that
um it does have a um restrictions on
that and it does give the financial
responsibility for the program to the
Department of Education so they're the
ones that will decide how to fund it and
how to implement it it gives them the
authority to do so so what we're saying
is that we're going to amend the bill so
that it gives the responsibility of
creating this pilot program to the
Department of Education with their rules
that they think should be applied to the
program
thank you represent gold you wish to
speak to your second
no I think representative Grody said it
all okay any comments representative
blackis
um an actual I'll answer the the good
question that was posed which is I do
not believe that formal education should
start as early as Pre-K so on the policy
point of view I don't agree with the
bill
I'd like to say something yes
representative
so here's my stance on this um I would
never support this bill whatsoever until
we could actually get a handle on the
indoctrination that's going on in our
schools and it is going on in our
schools because I've been speaking with
the teachers and the parents and they
all agree that this is getting out of
control so until we could get a handle
on that I would never Vote for This Bill
thank you okay other representative care
heart
I would just say that in general
from what I've seen at least in my
district the public school the the
proficiency rates are just really really
bad and I just don't think adding more
to their plate at this time is the right
way to go
thank you anyone else
Jefferson Bieber
just one more comment
during testimony it was made clear that
the parents
would be involved in these three and
four-year-olds three years old sitting
in front of a computer
um trying to learn I think that we've
all heard how what a disaster
remote learning during covid was so
that's also why I will vote ITF thank
you madam
represent Dolan
thank you madam chair my calling raised
a key point that concerns me that if the
if the availability of funds for this
program was a one-time uh
insertion into the uh into the budget
uh yet this bill would make the
expenditure of those funds a permanent
recurring event uh to me that's a
disconnect that's uh
hits it under the funding side and quite
frankly could be a violation of uh of
our constitution as an unspunded mandate
if you look Beyond Year One
thank you anyone else representative
true
thank you madam chair and a good
question of the chair
um is there an end
to the pilot program that I missed line
21 says it's three year
thank you madam chair but
there's nothing so permanent as a
temporary government program
anyone else representative goalie
thank you madam chair just a quick
question for representative Brody you
did say the commissioner of Education
was before the subcommittee and
supported this
the Deputy Commissioner of Education was
here
before subcommittee to represent him and
herself in supporting this program
's questions
in that case the motion is to adopt
amendment
0376h to house bill 620.
and the clerk can call the role
representative Simon no representative
Lakers no representative Bailey no
representative Santo nastasso no
representative true no representative
Dolan no Representative no
representative Gerhard no
the court approach no representative
Rhoda
yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes
representative shuitt yes representative
O'Brien
yes representative massimillo
representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes
representative Susie
10 yay 10 nay
excuse me oh I'm sorry and the chair
I'm going to vote Yes because I think
the amendment improves the bill
drastically okay I stand corrected
um 11 yes
9A all right so we have adopted the
emotion represent the uh representative
crota yes I have a motion of otter pass
with Amendment otpa on House Bill 620
with Amendment
376. is there a second
second
a representative goalie okay
any further discussion
I will say that I voted in favor of the
amendment because it eliminates
the department which I was strongly
opposed to
but I'm still going to vote against
ought to pass with Amendment because I
don't think
we should be getting involved in pre-k
education on as a government certainly
not at the state level
anywhere else
okay
seeing none the motion is ought to pass
with Amendment on House Bill 620.
and the clerk can call the rule
representative Simon no
representative Lucas no representative
Bailey
no
representative Santo nastasso no
representative true no representative
Dolan no
representative bear no representative
Garrett
in Clerk of folks you know
representative yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative shuitt yes representative
O'Brien yes
representative massimilla
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Susie
and the chair no
we have a vote 10 yay 10 a
all right this is another one that will
be going to the floor with no
recommendation representative lekkis
you'll write them out the
report in favor of ought to pass and
representative grow to that in favor of
what excuse me of itl excuse me you'll
and represent Broda will write the
report
ought to pass with Amendment correct
okay
all right
well let's go to something a little more
a little lighter
uh
House Bill 183 representative goalie you
had a motion
move to retain
I'll spell 183. okay is there is a
second okay second is by representative
Simon do you wish to speak to your
motion
sure
I I think I mean we heard the breakdown
was basically 75 25 on
retired versus firefighters who are
employed working at the Academy but
um and watching the subcommittee and
looking at the numbers coming out we
couldn't get a real handle on the actual
numbers of retired firefighters and how
many of those that are retired working
at the Academy would take advantage of
increasing hours I think it would be
helpful if we had exact numbers because
if this is only going to benefit four or
five individuals passing legislation for
a small group of people I don't think is
necessary and I think until we have
those actual numbers that we can work
off of to see if this would work to get
more people working over at the Academy
or not we need those Baseline and so
until we get that moving retain we okay
representative Simon thank you madam
chair there were a number of unanswered
questions and a lot of information that
we didn't have
um
if we were to pass this piece of
legislation right now it has the
potential to affect
um
other other groups as well who may want
to do the same thing and I would like to
have a better handle on what the
ramifications of that would be I also
don't want to just kill it because I
think it has Meriden it's something that
we need to be concerned about so we'd
like to look into it further
and the clerk can call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative a bear yes
representative Gerhard yes
the Clearfield Jess representative yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shuitt yes representative O'Brien
yes representative massimillo
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative soucy and the chair yes
20 years all right I know my report is
needed so
or unlock
House Bill 193
representative leckis
I like to move
um let me find it here ought to pass uh
with an amendment
and I will have that in a moment here
all right while you're getting the
amendment is there a second
thank you
I'm very disappointed in previous years
the opportunity to show support without
having to write a committee report
usually got a dozen
seconds
um
the amendment is uh 0 22 h
um and
people call this this bill was a clean
up a number of sections in the um the
language around
you know the retirement system statutes
this was at the request of
the retirement system some of them were
where there were conflicting areas in
the statute um
there was a change in the name of one of
the um
you know the standards boards that
they're required to adhere to and that
had to require changes in here the
amendment has to do with teacher job
share and um
I guess for teachers there are
situations where two of them share
a job and that was not um
and and it's and the other then
originally the bill allowed for that but
only if they were on different days
and it turns out that some of them will
do the morning some of the afternoon
still split days and then there was a
further redo the amendment that they're
not always
um 50 50. so the amendment allows
um a little more variance than that and
it's uh the amendment is is okayed by
the uh
by the retirement system I was actually
at the request of the teachers union so
okay
no I think it was explained very well
okay anyone else have comments questions
okay the motion is to adopt Amendment
zero zero two h
to house bill 193.
and the book control
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative San Antonio Sasso yes
representative true
yes representative Dolan yes
representative a bear yes representative
Gerhard yes clerk will Jess
representative yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative shuitt yes representative
O'Brien
yes representative massamilo
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative soucy and the chair yes
20 years here only all right we have
adopted the amendment
uh represents like as you move out to
pass with Amendment
I do yeah
I'll second okay
um do you wish to speak speak any
further
I don't representative Simon
representative likis is too good of a
speaker to come after so I'll pass
does anyone
anyone else in that case the motion is
ought to pass with Amendment
0022 and the clerk can call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
Lucas yes representative Bailey yes
representative santoso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative a bear yes
representative Gerhard yes the clerk
votes yes representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shuitt yes representative O'Brien
yes
representative massimillo
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Susie
and the chair yes 20 years uh Madam
chair I appear I may be a good speaker
but I'm not as organized I should be I
gave you the wrong amendment number
uh that was the earlier version
um so can we reconsider or whatever the
correct yeah
I think that's an editorial correction
since we know that you meant the right
Amendment what is the correct zero two
six nine H and my apologies to the
committee
oh 269 and perhaps you have copies of
that Amendment
um
don't we all have to have a copy of the
amendment to vote on it or no
depends on how much you trust
representative blackis now I don't know
how much you do uh it is though zero two
six nine H is as I described and the
difference between 22h and 0269h
is the allowing for splits other than 50
50. it allows 50 50 60 40 and 70 30.
which the retirement system was all
right with they didn't want it to go
further than that all right I think we
will
going at this for I think we will take a
short break to end representative
blackis will get copies of that
Amendment for all of us and we will
decide if we need to whether that's what
we thought we were voting on or not how
short is the break 10 minutes I'll run
right up
yeah it just splits it down to 70 30.
yeah
did you pick them up
no okay representative person I don't
think so sir
um
okay so I'm just my only concern is I
mean I guess it doesn't matter all that
much just making sure that everybody is
in support and doesn't have any problems
with it that's why you have to meet
that's why you have I mean OLS will be
there
you're myself
for the committee we have we have
received a very nice thank you note from
Heather it's posted on the board
she thanks us for our our farewell gift
and invite us to stay in touch so we
will do so
and
has everyone had a chance to look at
Amendment 0269
I guess so okay is this what you thought
you were voting on
yes okay in that case we will consider
the previous amendment number and
editorial mistake and
keep this
all right on House Bill 258 uh I don't
want to take that up today because
um
the the chiropractors and the
veterinarians are still talking about it
is that correct representative Lucas
uh Yes actually the Chiropractic board
is okay with what we're looking at doing
which was just require nationally
recognized certification I heard back
from one member of the vet board that
they're okay with the plan but the whole
board doesn't meet till the 15th so we
have to hear their I want to wait to
hear their official okay response and
that is not a an early bill so we can
postpone it to to a later and I'll
schedule a subcommittee meeting there
after that so we can consider it don't
look at me I was just an alternate on
yourself yes oh that's right
you were you were there with us for
everything so
we I guess you adopted us
okay so who else was it
representative true yes
um
on uh on House Bill 193 we voted to
accept the amendment
did we vote
otpa yes we did
it was 20 to nothing does anyone object
to consent on House Bill 193.
hope not that's a perfect consent bill
all right and an announcement
is there a fiscal dump
there is but it's less than ten thousand
so I think we're okay yes
yes
all right
um
yes please
thank you very much Madam chair uh I'm
just going to let everyone know I'm
officially calling a subcommittee
meeting on HB 436fn local
for Friday morning at 10 A.M we got to
keep that ball rolling so Friday morning
10.
[Music]
what is moo is recessed until one
o'clock on the 15th which is when we
have a an executive session scheduled on
House Bill 655 which is going to be
canceled because it doesn't need to be
done quite that soon
so we'll get back to the retirement
system at one o'clock Wednesday
I'm sorry madam chair can you please I
was sort of in the middle of walking in
putting stuff down can you please
explain again there's going to be a
subcommittee hearing on a subcommittee
working session on House Bill
436 Friday morning in parallel with the
655 work session
I we will not have
an executive session
on Friday afternoon
we will have the executive session on
House Bill
um
436 at one o'clock on
Wednesday
the 15th
the other any other Bill we don't get to
we will
um
exec at some later point because they're
not it's not up against the deadline
yes there is already one subcommittee
meeting on House Bill 655 that's been
scheduled for a while that's for
representing broder's subtle committee
representative Simon subcommittee will
be meeting at the same time in a
different room on House Bill 436. when
you expect to exec 655
lateral it has been changed to not be an
early bill so there's no need to vote on
it next week
and if I could
um get a status on House Bill 250 are we
going to look at that again later today
or what is it we will get to that later
today when representative Schmidt gets
back okay thank you
so everybody I hope everyone is thinking
about that
um so we're not doing 250.
so representative grow to you have a
motion on House Bill 691 I believe
is that the one you get or did I get I
think it's 391. 391.
I do
I have a lovely Amendment here that came
as a result of a subcommittee meeting
that we had with the sponsor of the bill
and the DHHS
which I will pass out there you go
it is amendment number
152h and essentially
the um
okay the amendment before you speak on
to it is there a second oh I'm sorry
thank you so um and they were this part
had this Bill had two parts the first
part was the part that we were all
having issues with the second part
changed the reporting from six months to
a year which
um
stayed unchanged as a result of the
subcommittee meeting everyone's in
agreement with part two and um so the
only the only thing that Amendment the
amendment does is Char change part one
and merely updates the language to enter
into a memorandum of understanding we no
longer use a memorandum of agreement as
the nomenclature
so
um we changed it to update into a
memorandum of understanding on
Cooperative regarding data sharing
between the Department of Health and
Human Services and the Department of
Environmental Services
which is something that everybody agreed
to and they do appreciate having the
testing going from every six months to
every year so I hope that the committee
will
recommend to adopt the amendment to
House Bill 391. okay thank you
representative shuitt
oh ditto
excellently said does anyone else have a
comment on the amendment
no reps on a shoe it did
okay in that case the motion is to adopt
amendment 0152 to House Bill 391 and the
clerk can call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
lakis yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative a bear yes
representative Gerhard yes clerk well
Jess representative groda
yeah Schmidt
he's not here oh I'm sorry representing
goalie yes
representative Jewett yes representative
O'Brien yes
representative massamila
representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes or is it
representative Gould yes representative
Susie
and the chair yes 19 yay zero nay all
right you if emotion represents brother
how do I move OT out of paths with
Amendment on House Bill 391 with
Amendment zero one five two h
is there a second
second
okay
all right Dylan
all right is there any uh
discussion
dollar anyone else
okay in that case the motion is ought to
pass with Amendment on House Bill 391
and the clerk called the rule
representative Lucas uh Simon yes
representative blakis yes representative
Bailey yes representative Santo nastasso
yes representative true yes
representative Dolan yes representative
a bear yes
representative Gerhard yes
clerk rolls yes representative
yes
representative goalie yes
representative shuitt yes representative
O'Brien yes representative massamila
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Susie and the chair yes
19 years all right the motion passes
19-0 is our only objection to consent
okay seeing none we'll put that one on
consent
uh representative Crowder you have
emotion on House Bill 409
I do
um I like to move Amendment let me just
see if I can find it in my pile aha here
it is amendment 353 h
I will pass it out so I like to move
Amendment
353h for House Bill 409. no I'll second
second by representative black is okay
foreign
thank you madam chair um this bill
um
is
um is a result of a subcommittee that we
that's the licensing sub give me on on
House Bill 409
um the language was to the original
language was to strike the sentence
um other states licensing requirements
are substantially equivalent or higher
two than those of the state
and the recommendation from oplc rightly
so was to make sure that the applicant
held the current license in the in that
other state that was in good standing
and the definition of good standing is
that which is defined by rules which are
the current board rules which are found
in RSA 13 as 313 a colon 8 sections one
and two
so this was actually
um
discussed with the cosmetology barbering
board and they support the amendment and
they support the action of the bill as
amended so I would imagine that we would
support this amendment
thank you representative blackis uh
ditto covers it okay anyone else have a
question or comment
all right seeing none the motion is to
adopt Amendment zero three five three h
to House Bill 409 and the Turk and call
the roll
representative Simon yes representative
Lucas yes representative Bailey yes
representative San Antonio yes
representative true
yes representative Dolan yes
representative yes representative Gerard
clerk vote Yes representative grotta yes
representative goalie yes representative
shewitt
yes representative O'Brien
yes
representative massamilo representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Susie
and the chair yes 19 years all right and
you have a motion represent grota
otpa own house bill 409 amended with
um
0353h
and I'll second okay
any further discussion
seeing none the clerk can call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative sampton yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative Weber yes
representative Gerhard yes clerk roaches
representative groda yes
representative goalie yes representative
shuitt
um I was going to make an adverse
comment but since 409 is one of the
favorite songs from my youth I will vote
Yes
representative O'Brien
yes representative massimilla
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative soucy and the chair yes
19 years all right is there any
objection to consent the motion passes
all right seeing them we'll put that one
on consent
representative shuitt if uh you'll
refrain from making that God verse
comment I will refrain from singing that
song at you
okay uh Arizona Hospital 109.
find it here
foreign
all right
one never knows Dustin no no I've got it
um I'd like to make a to a move on to
pass for the amendment
um
and I've got this one right this time uh
zero two one four h and I'm passing them
the amendment that we talked about
during committee I think we talked about
that I believe that's the one that adds
exemptions
okay for 109. yeah I'll second the
motion okay
what
yeah
you can make sure I didn't make a
mistake
okay was to speak to your motion I do
this uh Incorporated two amendments
um the first one was the one
presented by representative McGuire that
was uh replace some items in the first
list that were inadvertently left off
and then it adds
um
the new paragraph at the bottom and it's
just makes it clear that
um other practices like recreational
therapy to do things that could be
considered similar to occupational
therapy do not need to be licensed under
the occupational therapy
they're handled they're licensed
separately
all right that's excellent
um representative grow did you wish to
comment
no thank you okay does anyone else have
a comment
my goodness
in that case the motion is to adopt
Amendment zero two one four h to House
Bill 109 and the clerk can call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
lakis yes representative Bailey yes
representative santoso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative yes
representative Gerhard yes clerk roaches
representative groda yes representative
Schmidt
well he's not here representative goalie
yes representative shewitt yes
representative O'Brien
yes
representative massamila
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Susie
and the chair yes 19 years all right
representative blackis
I'd like to move
um
ought to pass with Amendment 0214h on
House Bill 109. one second okay
any further comments all right
representative Marcus Baroda no okay
anyone else
well it's a prime sponsor I'd like to
thank the subcommittee for fixing what
in retrospect is now an obvious
oversight in the bill
and I appreciate it and I'm going to be
for supporting it
and when else in that case the motion is
off to pass with Amendment on House Bill
109 and the clerk can call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
lakis yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative aware yes
representative Gerhard
look we'll just
representative groda
yes
representative goalie yes representative
shrewitt yes representative O'Brien yes
representative massamila representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
soucy yes and the chair yes 19 years
motion passes 19-0 is there any
objection to consent
seeing none we'll put that one on
consent
all right and
uh now we're gonna Schmitz is going to
make and that 250 also
um
house bill 266.
did that go to subcommittee
yes I think it went to representative
[Music]
and it didn't go to ours mine
sounds like a no
all right let's see
um does anybody know when we have a
hearing on that I'm sorry
no we don't have a subcommittee I have
nothing in my okay
um I couldn't move I mean if anybody
wants to I could move on a pass on House
Bill 266 if anybody wants us
okay
okay it was
like
okay
um so House Bill 266 and I'm sorry I
don't have my bill in front of me but it
does um basically codify what should be
happening in for hybrid and and virtual
agencies
hybrid meetings I'm so sorry let me let
me start that over
this is what is actually should be
happening with hybrid and virtual agency
meetings because we went from a
situation where we were having all
virtual meetings to those hybrid
meetings there was some discussion and
some
um it was it was necessary for us to
actually write to codify what should be
happening in these agency meetings so
that was the purpose of this bill
yeah
maybe I'd like to say that it was it it
is essentially what the governor imposed
as emergency rules during the emergency
of covid and it worked out fairly well
for some meetings
does
meet the requirements of 91a but it does
not authorize any remote or hybrid
meetings
it just says if you're going to have one
this is what you have to do
and so that's the intent of the bill
anyone else have a comment or a question
representative Schmidt okay good
okay thank you thank you yes
representative since we're no longer
under the emergency order from the
governor does this does that complicate
uh
processing it yes it means that they
that if a board wishes say to hold a
hybrid hearing on their rules so that's
more convenient for people to call in
or witness it
without actually having to come to
Concord this says these are the things
you have to do to comply with the right
to know law
thank you
anyone else
all right seeing seeing no one else the
motion is ought to pass on House Bill
266 and the clerk can call the roll and
can I just ask that the clerk not call
me since I was not here for the motion
you got it
representative Simon yes representative
Lagos yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo estaso
yes representative true yes
representative Dolan yes representative
yes representative Gerhard yes clerk
vote Jess representative Gorda
yes representative goalie yes
representative shewitt yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative Master Miller yeah
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes where it's
representative Gould yes
representative soucy yes and the chair
yes
19 years
okay the motion passes is there any
objection to consent
another one for consent okay
uh representative Schmidt you have a
motion on cacr1
I I do Madam chair I move ideal
okay is there a second
okay Schmidt and Bailey
you wish to speak to your motion
uh yes uh everybody should know uh so
as much as I admire representative the
sponsor shall I say the sponsor's
enthusiasm for the exciting potential of
a lieutenant governor uh I I don't think
that should be a real Criterion for our
decision as to whether this is a wise
idea and the bottom line really for me
is that this is this system has been in
effect for something like 240 years in
that time to my knowledge we've had
three occasions in which the lieutenant
governor uh certainly in the last 100
years or so three occasions in which the
lieutenant in which a lieutenant
governor had we had one would have had
to step in for the governor two of them
were when former governors resigned
their office a day or two before the end
of their term to be able to be sworn in
uh as U.S senators okay one was governor
Hassle and the other one was governor
Greg I think I may be wrong about that
the other occasion was when former
Governor Hugh Allen died in office
and and the Senate President took over
for
I think about a month
so the system works the framers put it
together uh to be Thrifty and we still
try to be Thrifty here I think in New
Hampshire and and and so that's on the
one side but also I think that
this plan is very ill-defined in terms
of how it would work and what it would
cost
what it would cost I the sponsor seems
to think it could be done for one
person's
150 a year
uh dependium and so forth
and I think the the lieutenant governor
would have to have a driver you're not
going to have this person driving all
over the state speaking on behalf of the
governor because he or she is going to
do something besides sit there and and
wait for the governor to become
incapacitated
and as I said we have not had that so
the person is going to have a driver
slash bodyguard just like the governor
does it's a State Trooper okay but
somebody's going to answer the telephone
the lieutenant governor is not going to
be answering his or her own telephone uh
and they're going to be some staff
people so I think this is going to be a
lot pricier than
than what the sponsor thinks and it it
is as I used to say Ann Landers said if
it ain't broke don't fix it our system
is not broken and we should not do this
so thank you all answer any questions if
anybody has one
really
I believe representative Schmitz
hit it right on my head oh all right
thank you anyone else representative
fleckis and then shewitt thank you
um yeah the prime sponsor is a good
friend and he raised what is potentially
a real issue which could have been uh to
one side serious disadvantage in 2019
and 2020 however
um you know adding having someone who is
elected but has nothing to do I think is
a
an opportunity for mischief and uh and
I'm willing to accept that risk and the
risk is on both sides so uh
I don't think we need to do this thanks
I'm sure
thank you madam chair
yeah I think first off that this is a
little unrealistic that at the cost that
was put forward particularly I will
state in answer to representative
Schmidt's comment and on behalf of the
women who are in government the person
who did replace
Governor Hugh Allen was destroy the
Senate President thus becoming
technically the first female governor of
New Hampshire so that worked out to be a
good thing
okay excellent representative
yes just one comment so
um I I respect the sponsor however I
agree with everybody's comments and then
one last comment is that the Senate
President does not make sense for any
checks and balances in place and so
maybe in the future this legislative
body May might come up with a bill that
would support someone else on staff such
as the five executive counselors that
exist right below the governor and still
in the governor's Branch thank you
thank you anyone else have a comment
all right seeing none the motion is an
expedient to legislate on cacr1 by
representative Schmidt and the clerk can
call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
lakis yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nosasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative yes
representative Gerhard yes clerk votes
yes representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shuitt yes representative O'Brien yes
representative massamilo representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Susie
and the chair yes
20a0na does anyone have an objection to
consent the motion passed 20-0
I'd known you were going to be unanimous
I would made motions more often
it's due to your eloquence
representative Schmidt
and good
ah it's also due to good selection of
bills to make motions on
all right we'll put this one on consent
also and
all right let's go back to house bill
250.
uh you withdrew your motion
representative Simon do you wish to make
it a motion I would Madam chair thank
you I would like to move lots of pass on
HB 250.
okay is there a second representative
goalie second
all right
you should speak to your motion
um yes after a testimony from the New
Hampshire retirement system it's
representative
um
the intent of the bill was what I had
previously thought or close to
previously what I thought it was
um I feel like if one of our group two
employees dies uh
in the line of duty protecting us that
this is the least that we can do for
them and once again the fiscal note on
an assessed small that can barely
calculate it so just seems reasonable
and common sense to me
representative goalie to speak to you
thank you madam chair yes
as was said earlier that
there is the option to choose 100 for
your surviving spouse have you should
you retain
retirement age
and pass away after you retire
so if you retired
and heaven forbid you dropped it two
days after retirement your spouse can
collect 100 percent
currently the way the law is
if you die in the line of duty
you only get 50 percent
now if that line of duty death could be
one day before retirement had you
retired and dropped a day later you'd
get the 100 so I think it's a matter of
codifying the statutes and making sure
you have the ability to get the same
amount
just uh my opposition before was based
on confusion over the bill which luckily
we got cleared up okay thank you
represent baber and then she would thank
you madam chair I'll just uh Echo what
representative O'Brien presented which I
thought was rather poignant uh
particularly if a young
first responder dies in the line of duty
his family has
set up their whole budget to pay the
house payment to put the kids through
college what have you and if he or she
is
income gets reduced by 50 percent that
upsets that plan for that whole family
and perhaps even prevents them from
being able to pay off the house puts
them on the street that's just not right
so I definitely support ought to pass
representative
thank you madam chair I support
ought to pass also and during the break
I did speak with Marty from our
retirement system in
in a corrective action
for myself alone that I will share with
everybody else I've asked Marty to fill
out a graph that I filled out for him
that will give us very clear specifics
give us a
um
a real life example and will give us a
before and after graph with monies tied
to it with number of people affected and
um that's what we use in the Aerospace
and defense industry and I think it will
work well for our committee as well and
prevent what happened a few minutes ago
thank you okay
representative
thank you madam chair
um I I cannot support the the ought to
pass
for a number of reasons
um
I don't know when this accidental
benefit was first created
but I will assume it's been on the books
for a while
and that
people coming under this provision of
the retirement
new
what their benefits were
um
if if towns wanted
to come up with an accidental death
benefit for their employees
I'm sure that there's a way they could
come up with a very inexpensive term
life policy
for the employees if that's something
they wanted to uh to pay for
when I read the Constitution
and because I don't have it right in
front of me I will paraphrase Thou shalt
not downshift
it does not it does not say
you can downshift if it's just a little
bit
it doesn't say that
it just says Thou shalt not downshift
and if the state wants to pay for this
that's certainly another issue
but in this case
this benefit costs money
and who's paying for it
the towns
and that is why I cannot support the
bill
because Thou shalt not downshift not
even just a little bit
thank you madam chair okay
thank you anyone else have a comment
well yes representative Bailey
yes please
uh article 28a mandated programs the
state shall not mandate or assign any
new expanded or modified programs or
responsibilities to any political
subdivision in such a way as necessitate
additional local expenditures by the
political subdivision unless such
programs or responsibilities are fully
funded
by the state or unless some such
programs or responsibilities are
approved for funding by a vote of the
local legislative body of the political
subdivision
very good representative Gerhart
in accordance with 28a would it be
possible to
have the political subdivisions vote if
they wish to Institute such a
benefit or
no they do have they do vote to accept
the retirement system it's it's the
modified that makes it an issue
follow-up follow-up I'm saying in this
particular
bill could they vote to opt-in
no
no it
it's the legislator votes to modify the
pension system to this extent the towns
will accept it
and they don't get a vote
anyone else
ah so that the 50 of pay is
was adopted by the towns and
municipalities when they went into the
pension system but the going to 100
percent is a
the 20th 2023 change that is not going
to be voted on by the towns
representative Schmidt
I'm not sure if it's 100
no apropos for this particular situation
but uh about I don't know 17 or years
ago or something like that we had a
proposal for uh I think a hundred
thousand dollar payout for uh Jeff
represent Gauley that comes out of the
general fund representative say what
100 000 dollar benefit comes out of the
of the fund exactly what but the thing
was that there was a proposal for I
think I was the only one here here then
uh other than that representative goalie
that's why I'm asking him to pay
attention so that because I want you to
corroborate or correct me if I'm wrong
um there was a proposal for a hundred
thousand dollar death penalty for First
Responders as I recall right
um and we looked at initially it was
going to be an insurance policy of some
sort and they looked at the we looked at
it and the cost of the insurance policy
vis-a-vis the likelihood that there
would be such a death penal benefit
um was so much disparate that that we
decided to do it out of the general fund
and we've had very few of those in the
16 or 17 years since that's happened
they saved a lot of money in other words
vis-a-vis what we would have paid for an
insurance policy so I'm not sure if
that's absolutely germane to this
discussion but I wanted to make sure
everybody knew
uh yes it's not exactly Jermaine because
this benefit increase is being charged
to the retirement system and unless we
terminally funded up front it will be
used to increase the local rates
however small the difference may be
anyone else
right I'm
inclined to vote for this although if
bills related similar to this are having
similar facts come in the future I think
a number should be more comfortable if
they were fully funded by the state and
avoid this problem
comments
okay thank you
the motion is ought to pass by
representative Simon and the clerk can
call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey no
representative Santo nosasso no
representative true no
representative Doland yes
yes representative a bear yes
representative Gerard
no
vote Jess
representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes
representative shuitt yes representative
O'Brien yes
representative Mass Miller
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes
representative Susie
and the chair
no
15 yay
5 nay
okay the motion passes it will be on the
regular calendar does someone wish to
write a Minority Report representative
true will write a minority today indeed
a short one will do
oh yes
okay
it's here all right so I'm not finishing
on a high note House Bill 180
representative Rhoda you have a motion
I do
I would like to move Amendment zero
three five two authored by myself and
representative Lucas
and I will second it okay if you'd pass
the amendment around oh of course I'm so
sorry I'm looking at all the copies and
I'm keeping them all to myself
well in this committee we like to share
okay representative Broda
yes so
I would like to know how many um I have
I don't know the answer to this but I've
we've heard this bill at least three
times in my lifetime probably more
and
um the main concern that everyone seems
to have in addition to having an
indigenous people's day is having it on
this particular day which is actually
not really celebrated as Columbus Day it
is actually celebrated as Italian
Heritage today
so this is a
strong step in One Direction
to change the name of Columbus Day as
Italian Heritage day as one of the
holidays that is celebrated in New
Hampshire
and that's it we're just changing the
name of Columbus Day to Italian Heritage
day
thank you representative you should
speak to your second I do
um I did this I support this for a
number of reasons one is um
I won't say anything unpleasant about
some of the folks that came to testify
before this committee but uh they made a
threat which is they're going to come
back forever until they uh get it passed
and uh
I figured this takes some ammo away from
that effort which which I support and um
the other thing that may be a little
more comfortable is uh well uh represent
I think petrigno
who yeah he was the one who spoke
eloquently against this bill
is on board with this amendment
um
and uh well I'm not entirely comfortable
with this going along this trend of
erasing people from history almost
anybody of significance from history has
done Terrible Things Columbus included
I think this is uh I don't feel strongly
but
um
those people irritated me I'm sorry to
say yes representative like as we
understand you're yielding to your base
of nature I I confess you okay
representative O'Brien thank you madam
chair uh I am going to support this I
would like to note representative Goode
and several others that did help you
with this I I think this is a true Olive
Branch that has been reached and as an
Irishman I support this my wife is pot
Italian most of us Irish kids married
some form of Italian wife you can only
boil the food so much
so I'll be proud this evening to go home
and tell that I support my Italian
friends thank you
thank you anyone else
I'm just a quick point of order question
um
it's not super different necessarily but
it's different enough I just want to
make sure that this is a Germaine
Amendment
if it is not
um
representative Broda and I were talking
about that this and if we send it in and
it is determined to be non-germaine we
will hold a
public hearing on the amendment and then
voted again
but I think it it's close enough to
Jermaine for in my opinion yes represent
Gould
thank you madam chair I just want to say
that for many of us who are Abenaki who
are native American we feel very
strongly that
um what what people choose to celebrate
is their business and so
um I think that representative
petrigno's testimony and then especially
representative O'Brien's comments about
um
about what the real start of of
um the day was about and and the fact
that it started in the north end with a
a horrible horrible bigoted hate kind of
situation so
um I really appreciate all the work
everybody's done and I strongly support
this all right thank you representative
Dolan yes thank you madam chair I'm
going to be supporting the amendment uh
but I I believe that the bill ought to
be ideal
okay thank you
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair well I've only
been to Italy one time and it was just
nipping down in the in the in the corner
and wasn't able to to visit any of the
fabulous cities of of Italy
um I certainly have seen plenty of
um
plenty of pictures of you know
Milano and many of the other great
cities of of
Italy and so forth and and you only have
to if you can even stand
Opera at all
and you've heard any of the operas of
Verdi
Aida and you know so many others as a
singer myself I've performed the manzoni
Requiem by PRD and a number of other
works of his
and the great Italian sculptors painters
and when you think that the initial
purpose of Columbus Day was to
rehabilitate the reputation of Italians
at a time when they were under
considerable assault in areas of this
country and Columbus was somebody
everybody had heard of even if he'd
never been to this to the American
Shores
so I think the idea of Italian Heritage
is something that if you don't know
enough about it yet uh well you can
start with pizza anyway in spaghetti I
can you can always make me happy by
inviting me for a spaghetti dinner or
pizza so I I think this is as
representative O'Brien said a moment ago
in Olive Branch in the direction of
getting out from underneath the idea of
trading Columbus Day for indigenous
peoples day and it's a step in the right
direction so I'm going to be voting yes
thank you yes representative Gould and
let me just say that um President Biden
this year declared both indigenous
people's day and Columbus Day for that
Tuesday in October and certainly we all
know as indigenous people or as
Abernathy people we can go to the
governor and ask for Proclamation
there's nothing in this action we're
taking today that prohibits or goes
against all the towns and municipalities
that have chosen to celebrate indigenous
people's day
good good to know anyone else
representative Simon
thank you madam chair I don't have any
particular malice towards the amendment
I'm not sure if I'll support it yet or
not I'm still thinking about it some of
my concerns are just by moving in the
direction of changing Columbus Day to
Italian Heritage day
um
I guess it opened like representative
O'Brien said should we change St Patty's
Day to Irish heritage celebration day I
didn't think you'd be as excited about
that
um I also just wonder we you know
obviously I have a great deal of respect
for
um all of the Italian members of the
United States of America and the state
of New Hampshire
um but we are representative of just
about every nation on the planet and if
we start naming things after countries
Heritage days
um I think we open up a whole slew of
opportunity for
um where's my Lebanese Heritage day and
where's my French heritage day
um
so that that is uh so one of the
concerns that I have uh with going in
this direction uh my other concern to
representative leikis's comments is I
don't think this will actually
ameliorate
um them from coming back again I I think
they're looking for something very
specific and they're very passionate
about it and I think they'll return even
if we do this
um because they're looking for the
indigenous people's day to be codified
so
um I'm not sure that it fixes that
problem and I think it opens us up to
potentially other problems as well so
representative
thank you madam chair
my my main concern with this is really
just having the government dictate
what's a holiday anyway when really a
holiday is a holy day and I think that's
kind of a personal decision so to go to
the people with the guns and say we want
this to be the official holy day I think
is kind of getting into weird territory
but on the federal level I always tend
to end up there the we are up to now 44
paid days for federal employees for all
the various holidays and I just
I think we've kind of gone over my point
being there's a point is I just don't
want to see New Hampshire end up
following the same route where we end up
with more paid days and work days
column this first of all even for the
the government holidays are not
necessarily paid days off
and
um Columbus Day is in fact a Federal
holiday under that name
yes follow-up follow-up this is actually
from a Forbes article and the quote was
this makes 44 paid days off the average
federal employee annually which is
nearly nine full weeks of paid time off
each year so
okay a representative wrote it and then
like us
I just want people to understand this is
not complicated
we are just codifying what we are
actually doing we're not adding any
holidays we're not changing anything
other than the name of the day to
represent what people are actually doing
they are celebrating their Italian
Heritage and we are codifying that by
changing the name of the day that's it
okay representative yep ditto it doesn't
add nobody gets another day off with
this
thank you madam chair
I can remember back in my youth
uh listening to uh Mao Zedong give a
speech
and I'm paraphrasing because my Mandarin
is really really rough
but he was saying that for their
cultural revolution they had to get rid
of the four holes
uh I think it was the old ways the old
customs
the old habits and the old ideas
and that is what that's why I don't
support the amendment I don't support
the bill
because that's what I see this as
a continuation of Erasure
thank you madam chair
anyone else
I like to say that I'm opposed to it
because I think Columbus accomplished a
great deal and regardless of his
personal moral failings
he changed the history of the world and
I think that's worthy of note
so I'm I'm not not in support
anyone else
okay we've all spoken our piece the
motion is to adopt amendment
30352 to House Bill 180 by
representative and the clerk can call
the roll
representative Simon no
representative Lucas yes
representative Bailey yes
representative San Antonio no
representative true no
representative Dolan yes
representative yes
representative Gerhard no
clerk votes no
representative groda
we
[Laughter]
do need a translator
representative Schmidt
I'm a former member Judy Judy would
appreciate your voting we in his name so
I will say yes
representative goalie yes
representative shewitt on behalf of
Italians see
representative O'Brien yes
representative Mass Miller
representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould uh-huh
representative Susie
represent uh in the chair no
so 14 yay six nay okay that motion is
adopted representative Grody who you
have a motion I do I have uh otpa motion
for House Bill 180 with Amendment zero
three five two h
end a second
by representative gold okay
any further discussion are probably
beaten this dead horse
okay thank you in that case the motion
is ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill 180 and the clerk can call the rule
representative Simon no representative
Lakers
uh conflicted but yes
representative Bailey
yes
representative San Antonio no
representative true no representative
Dolan no
representative
yes
representative Gerhard no
clear pose no representative groda
yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes
representative see
representative O'Brien yes
representative Miss Miller
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould uh-huh
representative Susie yeah
in the chair
no
I'm sorry one two
foreign
to seven
just quickly uh-huh is Abenaki for no
that's where you all got that from it's
uh-huh
so you voted yes were you voting yes or
no please we took it as yes
oh
okay fine I said it backwards fine we
assumed it was in English so that's it
all right the motion the motion passes
13 to 7. so that will go on the regular
calendar
does anyone care to write a Minority
Report I hope not
okay not seeing any will lead let the
minority uh
uh
go in silence
okay anyone else
I think that's the last we have to do
and
house bill
436 will have a subcommittee meeting
Friday morning
and will be exact next Tuesday which is
I believe the 15th
and House Bill 258 will be exact at some
point I believe we have to make it a
Time known so I'll put it on the 15th
but we'll push it out from there
okay
thank you all very much Madam chair can
you just make sure I'm over here and you
just confirm Who You're Expecting
reports from so that we don't
leave you high and dry I thank you I
appreciate that all right house bill 337
is representative schuette
449 doesn't need one
um
571 is
split report Simon and goalie
341 is
Santa anastasa with a Minority Report by
grotta
620 is a split Report with
lack Us in favor of itl and growed it in
favor of
ought to pass with Amendment
uh goalie again no no report
House Bill 193 lacus
391 is grota
409 is groda you're gonna
prioritize the more important ones uh
109 is Lexus
266 is grota
cacr1 is Schmidt
250 is Simon with true writing a
Minority Report and 180 is grota
so
whichever ones you want whichever ones
you want to get on the calendar turn in
first
sometime tonight please
and
thank you all we'll see you tomorrow for
some more something for some new builds
or in the early hours of the morning is
that acceptable I hope so
priority
I have that data I was taking notes yeah
I've got that
sure
I'll see you yes speak to the family if
you like it yes Chris